starting tonight at six eastern and
every saturday in july on c-span radio
this year marks the 50th anniversary of
the birmingham campaign a series of
peaceful protests of racial segregation
laws in the south that campaign was met
by attacks using high-pressure fire
hoses and police dogs on men women and
children producing some of the most
iconic images of the time
it's considered one of the major turning
points in the civil rights movement
and this morning c-span radio takes a
look at that era with oral histories
from two prominent civil rights leaders
james baldwin and vernon jordan
james baldwin was author an author and
playwright whose early works greatly
influenced the civil rights movement his
1953
semi-autobiographical first novel go
tell it on the mountain looked at life
for african americans in the south in
the first part of the 20th century
his 1955 work notes from a native son a
collection of 10 essays on the issues of
race in america and europe
in 1963 he wrote the fire next time a
study of the black muslim movement led
by elijah muhammad and malcolm x
in all james baldwin wrote james baldwin
wrote 19 works of fiction and
non-fiction from 1947 to 1985.
many focusing on the issue of race in
america he died of cancer in 1987 at the
age of 63.
in 2005 the u.s postal service created a
first-class stamp in his honor
the interview you're about to hear is
part of the robert penn warren civil
rights oral history collection at the
university of kentucky he recorded it as
research for his book on who speaks for
the negro published in 1965.
this runs uh about 50 minutes and we now
bring you robert pen warren's interview
with james baldwin recorded april 27
1964 on c-span radio in what sense uh mr
baldwin you
think the
revolution is a revolution how would you
relate to our
previous concepts of revolution
well that's a tough one to answer
because i'm not i'm not always sure that
um
the word revolution
is the right word i'm
i myself use it because i don't know
of any other
it's not
in my mind anyway um
like
it's not as simple as revolution of one
class against another for example it is
not as
clear-cut let's say is the algerian
revolution against french
it is
a very peculiar revolution because it
has to
in order to succeed at all
it has to have its aim the
reestablishment
of the union
and
a great a radical shift in the um
in american war it's an american the
american way of life
not only is it applied to the negro
obviously but if they applied everywhere
every citizen of the country
this is um
a very tall order and um
and desperately dangerous but
but inevitable in my in my view because
um
of the nature of our history the nature
of the american negroes relationship to
the rest of the country
all these generations and the algae the
countries had taught him which is simply
now
always was but now it's become overtly
and um and concretely intolerable
may i interrupt here for one moment
you say different from
a revolution like
the algerian which means liquidation of
a class of a of a another country's
control well any other regime
not liquidating the class either
something else
because the algerians and the french had
very great differences
partly simply because the algerians had
a country called algeria which happened
to be ruled by france and the
aim of the revolution there would have
had to be to to break the power of
french revolution then yes that's right
type
the
this is not that doesn't apply here at
all because this is
indeed in principle one nation it's
americans battling
to get rid of invader or to um or even
to destroy a class but um to liberate
themselves and their children
from um from what precisely from the
from the economic
economic and social sanctions imposed on
them traditionally
because they were slaves here
now there are some concrete things
involved in this i think you know i
think that um
for example
if washington
had the
energy to move to break the power of
people like senator eastland instead of
russell so the new girls began to vote
for the south he would have
made a large step forward negroes could
go to mississippi would have a different
state
if we get a different state mississippi
you could begin to have a different
country
i mean it's not as mystical or as um or
as fuzzy as people make it make it seem
it's um
it seems to me the south is ruled very
largely still
biology which rules for its own benefit
and it not only oppresses negroes and
murders them
but really imprisons
and victimizes the bulk of the white
population
you said once in prince
[Music]
that
the southern mob
does not represent
the will of the southern majority
i still feel that i think how would you
discuss that
well those mobs that fill the street it
seems to me
unless you know unless once they say the
south is populated entirely by monsters
those mobs that fill the street
our reflection i think of
the terror that all everybody feels is
done on the lowest level
and those mobs that fill the street have
been
uh used by
the american economy for generations to
keep the [ __ ] in its place the fact
they've done the
americans north and south by the way
they already worked for him they've
always been encouraged to do it
no one has ever even given them any hint
that it was wrong
and of course they're now completely
bewildered and and the mom the mob yes
and can only react in one way which is
which is through violence and same with
an uh alabama sheriff facing
a negro student
knows that he's in danger doesn't know
what the danger is and only all he can
do is beat him over the head or
counterparty there's no one else to do
all revolutions
of the ordinary historical type
have depended on say the
driving force of hope and the driving
force of hate
they're going somewhere and they are
mobilizing the adrenaline against
something
i suppose you could put this way then
other things may be involved with those
things now
when this is directed against
a regime to be liquidated
it's one thing
inside
of a system
which must be
reordered but not destroyed
maybe exactly reordered
then the hope hate ratio
might change
i think how the hate is accommodated
in a case like that this kind by quote
revolution
pulitzer prize-winning author and poet
robert penn warren interviewing author
and civil rights activist james baldwin
in april of 1964.
well american negro has had to
accommodate a vast amount of hatred for
since he's been here
and um
that was a terrible school to go through
i think though that it um
so far
and in this context
operates to um
operates to control what hatred was such
hatred as there is i don't i myself so
i'm accused of hating all white people
and saying what all negroes do
i myself don't feel that so much because
i feel a bitterness
um one's been too involved not to hate
anybody whom you raise you could despise
them you know you can uh
you have a great complex of feelings
about them and you may who you may even
if given moments won't kill them
but it wouldn't come under the heading
for me of the hatred the algerians felt
for the french which is obviously in one
level certainly much much less
complicated to a frenchman simply a
frenchman but here at your brothers and
your sisters whether or not they know
that they're your brothers and your
sisters
and that complicates it complicates it
so much that i can't possibly myself
quite see my way through this um as for
the hope
that is fuzzy too
hope for what
you know the best
people involved in this revolution
certainly don't hope to become what what
the [ __ ] of americans have become
so the hope begins and has to be to
create a new nation
under intolerable circumstances and very
little time and against the resistance
of most of the country you mean the hope
is not to
simply move into uh
white middle-class values is that it
believe it is that we're the hope it
isn't as a matter of fact but even if
that were the hope it would not be
possible
it is simply not possible for the church
for example to accept me into it without
becoming a different institution
i don't have to be deluded not to
realize that
and the church of course realizes which
is why you know which is why it isn't
about change what applies to the church
applies to politics applies to every
level of national life in order to
accommodate me in order to
to
overcome
so many centuries of cruelty and bad
faith and genocide and
and fear simple fear
all the all the american institutions
and all the american values
public and private we'll have to change
the democratic party right to become a
different party for example how do you
envisage
uh the
results of this movement if successful
[Music]
which is almost impossible to imagine
in this country
there's still a world in which
ultimately race would count for nothing
in which americans simply
not so simply
would grow up
enough to recognize that um
i don't threaten them
part of the problem here is not the
thing to do with race at all it had to
do with ignorance and to do it because
of you
undoubtedly that's true maybe hold that
though for a moment is one of the
points where other things can affect
this yes
some people say like oscar handlin and
other historians and sociologists
that equality
increases
rather than diminishes
the tendency of ethnic groups to uh pull
together
to define their
themselves as a group
that once the pressure of
of discrimination has been lessened or
removed
history so far of america has been for
the ethnic groups to coalesce rather to
dissolve
well i'm not sure i agree with that and
in any case i'm very well very badly
placed to answer it since um
the american negroes don't experience a
particular transformation you know and
and the ethnic group in this context can
only really refer to the american negro
because
the case
can't really apply to the irish
and not really finally to the jew but um
we're talking about the low man on the
american totem pole the man on who's
laid the this country
knows free labor this country was built
now what about this to the next
connection as a
question to speculate about for a moment
in the last few years
if
we can believe the sales of bleaching
creams and such things
and the allowed sentiments of many
negroes
there's a movement towards an acceptance
uh of and a pride in negro identity
as opposed to
an older tendency to uh
shift from that center not even the
actual passing or by changing
uh personality or appearance
this would seem to indicate something
wouldn't it
what i think it indicates is simply that
um
for the first time in in american negro
history or in american history
the american black man has not been into
the mercy of the american white man's
image out of this because of africa
in america because it has not been
reached it really has not been reached
but the question of a tendency or a will
is more defined i think i really think
it comes out of the fact that for the
first time in the member of anybody
living there african statesmen africa is
the worst of the western sources deal
with
africans on a level of power
author and civil rights activist james
baldwin being interviewed by poet and
author robert penn warren in 1964 on
c-span radio
and the image of one of the shipless
donkey and the uh
all that jazz and she lived so long was
shattered and
kids then
people had another image to turn to
which released them
it's still by the way you know after all
um
very romantic for an american girl think
of himself as an african but it's um
it's necessary it's a necessary step it
is in in
the recreation of his morale
in the matter of discussed long ago by
dubois
many other people said
of the possible split
in
[Applause]
the tendency to identify with the
african culture or african mystique or
the mystique noir or to other
uh even the american negro culture as
opposed to
american white culture there's a pull in
that direction
as opposed to a tendency to pull over
and
accept the uh western european american
white tradition as another pool
these things against each other are
candy anyway for some people they are
some people
uh be very troubled by this
you feel this question is real
well for yourself or your observation
well
i don't know how to answer that it um
my own case whatever whatever let me you
know whatever that means
it was very hard for me to accept west
and european values because they didn't
accept me
because um
any negro born in this country spends a
great deal of time trying to be accepted
trying to find a way to
operate within the culture and to
and not to be made to suffer so much by
but nothing you do works but how many
showers you take no matter what you no
matter what you do
these western values simply don't simply
absolutely resist and reject you
so that inevitably at some point you
know you turn away from them
or you re-examine them i think first you
turn away then perhaps you re-examine
them
because
there's something that slaves knew and
the masters haven't found it out yet but
the slaves who
you know who adopted that bloody cross
didn't know one thing they knew the
masses could not those masses could not
be christians because christians
couldn't have treated them that way
you know i mean this this this rejection
has been the very heart of the american
american eagle psyche from the beginning
let's take the african side of it you
have written on that
along the way
by covering that conference
piece about that uh that would imply a
difficulty but you have written there
would imply difficulty too
in identifying
uh with uh
i've got to be honest about that it's
almost it's not impossible but that at
that point certainly in my life and
i think that i think for many people and
until now
it's it's hard because it's all it's all
been buried it's hard as a matter for
that amount of africans who are only
only now beginning to
um image with a long colonial night
so there's a sense in which you can say
that africa the word word african the
very term
is european invention i'm not all
convinced people in the villages outside
of the cities think of themselves as
africans you know and after all it was
very it wasn't very long because the
italians think of themselves as italians
it's not the horizon
it's african-americans it's nothing not
not yet no
i just think it would take you know a
couple of generations
and in case of an american negro
africa you know which which part of
africa which africa would you be
thinking of you are you thinking of
senegal you think you have saint louis
you have
a middle free town
and if you ask humanity any of these
places what do you know about them
what and what is there that you can use
what is there that you can contribute to
these are
very great questions i don't think
there's
that
and the void is absolutely nothing that
no bridge can be can be made but i think
it's
we've been away from africa for 400
years no power in heaven allow me to
find my way back i can go back
and maybe even function there but i have
to be on terms which have yet to be
worked out
richard wright didn't find it very happy
did he no not at all
not at all i think richard went there
with the wrong side of assumption
but then
there's no way not to go there with the
wrong set of assumptions i did two in a
way you know
not rich's assumptions but
i don't know
i just know i just didn't know what i
would find and
what i found surprised me and and i must
say um sort of gladdened me
but um
i still would not be able to tell you
exactly what it was
and i still must be able to tell you
what my what my old relationship to it
is
do you remember what your assumptions
were
no i i
i guess i throw dark blocks out i
remember before i went i did my best to
discard whatever assumptions i might
have had though of course you never
succeed in doing that
you know
i i didn't realize but i realized before
you know that i was
in some way very european because that
was the way i've been
in any that's what i've been stained by
you know that they were
and i also that i was a puritan in the
sense that um
in a very serious sense in the sense
that africans are not in a sense of
being distrustful of the flesh
and a celebration and
and being restricted with the totally
western kind of self-consciousness which
i will always have i realized too that
that um
the reality of castration had been up
most of my mind has been in the in the
minds of almost any american you grow
male
uh
since you realized from the time i
realized i was a male
and this has done something to my psyche
no matter how i adjusted myself to it or
failed adjust myself to it it had been a
reality for me the way that it had not
been as far as i could tell from them
and this is robert penn warren a
pulitzer prize-winning author and poet
interviewing author and civil rights
activist james baldwin in 1964 on c-span
radio
on the question of leadership
and uh the struggle for power
i don't know if it's i don't know if
it's only a struggle of power i mean
there's some figures not nearly not
merely now
there's some figures in the movement or
on the periphery
who
impressed me as being
opportunistic no
but um
i think i think the problem is more
complex than i think it's involved with
the pressure being brought to bear um
on everybody by the by the people in the
streets especially
by the poor and by the young
so that
one is always in position of having to
assess very carefully once once tactics
one's moves in terms of the of the
popular desire because
what's got to avoid yet another danger
which is this that if the people feel
betrayed you've lowered their morale and
then nothing and then
you open the door on the holocaust
so there are some
things that people have agreed to the
wall in washington's very good example
it was not the most popular thing no
dreamed up it was not really known by
the leaders as far as i know it all
it was um
it was brought off because nobody could
call it off
nobody dared to call it off it's been
guaranteeing a you know a series of race
ride
how much was the idea based on the old
march on washington movement
of uh mayfield
very heavily i think no i wasn't in on
the you know i was not i was hardly ever
backstage on it
but but
um i think it springs from that that
event or at a board of events a boarded
event
in the 40s
[Music]
and it was a very significant day
even though it was we say contained and
but it was also a turning point i don't
think that i didn't think i thought then
i i still think that
we will never get 250 000 people to come
to washington again
because um the petition for redress or
grievances
how do you explain that
[Music]
well
i think that the negro in america has
reached the point of
despair and disaffection no and that
people now talk about no certain
technique techniques being used is
destroying the good will of white people
but nobody nobody gives a damn any law
any longer about the goodwill of people
whose good will has nothing has never
done anything to help you or to save you
their will can hardly do they can hardly
do more harm than their good willers and
their goodwill has
it's very significant this is a very
significant um
despair
yet you want to avoid the holocaust
indeed
we want to avoid the holocaust but you
see there
that is not really that is not simply in
the hands of negro leaders that's in the
hands of the entire that's in the hands
of
the entire country it's not a one-way
ticket it's not a one way to get at all
no
if you have people up there
filibustering about whether or not
you're human then obviously you're gonna
have a reaction in the streets
clearly no
and my farmer and king and all those
people are doing everything they can but
they cannot do it alone
it's certainly not possible the way the
holocaust one is going to have to have
some help and radial help forthcoming
you distinguish however
between what you might call legitimate
and illegitimate uh demonstration
well it's becoming increasingly hard to
distinguish between them you know i'm
not
is is the demonstration in front of the
florida pavilion the world's fair
legitimate or illegitimate
depends on the point of view i think
it's legitimate no well let's say that i
think so too as i do
uh
we can distinguish between
a school boycott
or a march on washington
yeah
i say an orderly demonstration inside
the fairgrounds
and
[Music]
yes there is there is some distinction
distinction will have to be i think in
terms of the
the clarity of purpose and the
likelihood of achieving any um
um monday once when they're not saying
concrete gains have been so few
but in terms of pinpointing a specific
dramatizing specific thing
issue
a specific target that's right yes yes
then it is uh it's beating but when it's
a random protest well then i think you
can do a vastly more harm than good
a random protest uh which may carry
grievous social consequences
you know of course this entire
revolution's going to carry grievous
social consequences but yes
that's always true it changes our
consequences yeah but the question of
the ambulance touching down the street
with a dying man is one thing as opposed
to the consequences of somebody having
to uh refurbish a tournament yeah yeah
that is one of the that's an area in
which when somebody has to play it
literally by ear you know
uh a school boycott depends very much on
where the school is
you know it depends on the whole complex
of issues of course a school boycott is
designed as i see it to dramatize the
situation in the schools which is really
that situation of the school but the
situation in the cities
author and civil rights activist james
baldwin interviewed by pulitzer
prize-winning author and poet robert
penn warren in 1964 on c-span media you
know it's not only the school boards
which are at fault so they are but it's
also the structure of our cities
which we just created which has created
this dilemma
and as well rent strikes the same thing
you know on the facebook when there's no
right not to pay the rent on the other
hand that i know there's a right to keep
you to keep you locked from the tenant
you know and and um
they penalize you in this way and the
only way to dramatize it is to stop
paying the rent
what about a policy deliberately
uh
directed
at uh
getting a little bloodshed for the
papers
i haven't really heard of this well i uh
out over the one case it's a member
sitting a man who sat in such a
meeting
uh told me any names of the other person
remember randy we've got to get a few
heads broken here we are going to lose
out
well i i know it sounds very unrealistic
to me since in the first place the
problem of getting heads broken doesn't
seem to be a problem at all
i don't i don't understand the nature of
that
well it's you know it's obviously madly
and criminally irresponsible
but um i haven't myself
come across that
seriously just as attack to get
i have you have just one case
documented at least i take the uh i take
the word of the money
i believe
i believe you it just seems insane to me
but since
i repeat it's just never been a problem
to get your head broken you didn't have
to no you don't have to go that range
you don't gotta arrange that
do you see this
building up that
congressman uh powell
said to me it was true the other day
that the old organization's on the way
out
for the organization
well i'm not sure i'm not so sure they
don't really count
but they're certainly either on the way
out or you know in the process of
radical changes
and that's this would this would you
wouldn't even be critical of them to
realize this because
there's certain things they will simply
have to do if they're going to remain
in positions of responsibility or
more power
which they never had to do before the
situation dictates it
so those who cannot do that are on the
way out yes
[Music]
you find an argument now and then such
as this one i heard from dr aaron henry
in mississippi
[Music]
that they
any acp approach
had made it possible
for a man to know
his uh
well rights
given a definition of his of his rights
it seems a little simplistic to me but i
see i see what he's saying i think
that history had given him this sense
yeah but i think it's more to his name i
think that um i think that's true
i think there's more to it than that i
think that the whole
stream of american history in a way has
done that even though i don't
even though it never intended to
and the events of the last 20 years done
that too
in terms of the naacp it was something
to me
would have to be talking about you had
to be talking about which chapter no it
would not apply to some chapters in the
north it would seem to me he was
thinking the long range effect you see
of the other various legal cases over 30
years well this would apply i think more
in the south and it wouldn't at all
much more much more in the south i think
i think it's a very different
organization on the southern edition
do you follow the line of thought that
this is dr kenneth clark uh takes
that the
dr king's
[Music]
method in itself has some merit but is
inapplicable in the north yes i'm a
failure i'm forced to agree with that
negroes in the south still go to church
some of them and it grows in the south
which is much more important
i still have something resembling a
family
around which you can
build a great deal but the northern
negro family has been fragmented for the
last 30 years
if not longer and once you haven't got a
family then you have another kind of
despair another kind of demoralization
and martin king can't reach those people
[Music]
but he doesn't know he can't reach them
well i think martin does know it no i
think that um he's determined to um
determine
he can't abandon them on their land
either
you know and um
it's not that his influence is
absolutely
absolutely negligible no he is still a
national
leader and an international figure
at bridgeport
well you can pack a hole in bridgeport
but it's very you know i i packed halls
too depends on what you're packing the
whole width yeah yeah you know i mean
the fact itself
can mean great many things
with well-dressed middle-class people
it's my observation
yeah
you know the boys in the pool room stay
in the pool room
and they're most and they're more
it's more important to reach them
you know to do something about their
morale and
it's not his fault at all
but you know to reach them is really
very difficult malcolm x can reach them
you know those those kids are not
christians and it's very hard to blame
for not being christian since there are
so few in this christian country let's
take some specific uh
episodes like the school busing program
in glendale
well i don't know anybody who has a very
clear notion of what they think about
that and i don't either
i have nieces and nephews who were being
bust for a while and some still are
and their parents took the attitude that
if the kid was willing to undergo this
then it was then maybe you know it was
worth it but no one no one thought that
it would it couldn't have any effect
really since after all those kids come
back home the same house to the same
house the white kids doing the black
kids doing
and
what happens in the school day it's not
going to make that much difference
i think the problem's going to be
attacked on another uh on another deeper
level
though i'm not an expert in these
matters well i thought god knows i'm not
i've talked to some people about it no
more than i do
like dr clark
yeah and uh then i've talked to dr uh
you know uh dodson uh
dan dodson and
a few people like that who have special
continuously special
there's a large group that takes the
view apparently
that the busting except the limited
fashion is is useless that you have to
go after a big crash program of building
schools
as best you can and then and and uh the
integration uh follow rather than
precede the process or at least be
considerable
but you can't make it as an arbitrary
outside uh
outside criteria robert warren
interviewing james baldwin in 1964 on
c-span radio to agree with that but it
gets to be a vicious circle because it's
not going to do any good to build
schools until you start building
neighborhoods
and we've we've seen in new york city
neighborhoods being destroyed the last
20 years for money
we're in the hands of you know gang of
real estate gangsters
you know and all the night there are no
neighborhoods in america in new york
anymore true and do you have
neighborhoods i don't see what you can
do much i don't see what there's what
you can do much about about schools
you see what i mean yes i do yes i do
of course there's the other proposal of
having the great school parks
straw from all sorts of neighborhoods
well that's a more interesting proposal
but it still doesn't get to the root of
the matter it does which is why we allow
the city to be to be run this way
but meanwhile somebody has to do
something
yes i quite agree the problem there is
is what in terms of schools
and i confess myself can be almost
completely baffled by it um
[Music]
limited busting school parks yes but
this
these things it seems to me
it means me it seems to me the sooner
they wanted to carry the battle straight
into the real estate real estate boards
and banks
that's where that's where that's where
the trouble is
well that's agree on that
oh but this is a peripheral question but
one that has some significance because
people are ready to shed blood on it
and um
mr galamson would say wreck the schools
unless we get integration
on my timetable immediately
almost immediately
remove that statement
this uh is the thought of such an
argument that makes
say the busing a symbol of a thousand
other things i know
uh this uh make a symbolic solution
rather than a real solution
well i'm opposed to
symbolic solutions and i
i don't i don't know reverend glamis i
don't know so i can't really
discuss his position
not as an attacker yeah i don't know
but i don't see any point in
trying to wreck a school system which is
very nearly wrecked already in any case
um
at least i don't see any point in saying
so
um
why can i go back to what i said what is
it what i said before in the first place
obviously you know going to try to be
responsible and all this
you can't say you may determine your own
mind but you can't say you know we'll
have integration of my terms at once or
not at all because if you're going to be
realistic about it you have to be
hard to try
one's got to realize that it will take
some time the trick is to get it started
you know and in this context especially
one's not going to get it started it
seems to me by inflammatory statements
of that kind
well after all one's trying to save the
children
if one's trying to do anything
it does seem to me that one's got one's
got to sue for some real confrontation
between the city
and the schools between the city between
the city that is and the
and the indian forces of integration
that's where the problem is
i appear that that is where the problem
is well it would seem it's uh that is
the root problem yeah
and the other things are involved other
things are involved in that and the
tactics i suppose when as one has
evolved and would have to have there as
a purpose to bring about this
confrontation
and that's a very delicate
incendiary matter or abilities are
measures along the way well the reality
measures along the way are really
probably going to be doomed to failure i
think one's got to bring about the
confrontation
because what immediately what immediate
measures in effect really can the city
can anybody
make bring about in this
situation if i'm not mistaken dr clark
is prepared
i don't want to be certain of this
prepared to accept a period of
non-integrated lower grades because it's
a massive difficulty
aim for
high school
integration
or upper heart well that seems that
would seem on the face of it i've not
talked to to ken
and i repeat i'm not an expert in it but
i think i can see why he would why he
would take that position on the face
that i would tend to agree you know
i would because the massive
complications of the option yes exactly
exactly
i think that there might be much more
hope in that
so it's uh well still it's obviously a
half measure
it really is
when do we how do we get whole measures
you know well i think you probably get
whole measures by by dealing with a
great many half measures that's the two
things all right yeah
not call a half measure a whole measure
himself yeah yeah exactly exactly
well we sound very wise on that point
don't we yeah oh my god
abstract
i think that's a bad thing to ken is
right about that
i have a quotation here from oscar
hanlon's new book
may i read it two years ago i read my
writing
the general disillusionment says 54 he's
talking about boy are you ready for book
building tonight no
the attention of negroes has focused on
one cause segregation
and on one cure integration
they have come to consider racial
separateness
the root of difficulty
and racial balance as a sole solution
in a rally this conclusion
they have paradoxically enough
accepted
the contention of the white separatists
and white supremacists
but there is really
no difference between the north and the
south as a result of this development
the package of civil rights movement has
shifted
and racial balance becomes a primary
objective rather than
or equality and justice
president immigration becomes
rather than
an element they're not taking
a paraphrase from other things he said
about it
well
it's it's
not such
it's not such a recent development and
none of on a54
i concluded and i know every [ __ ] i
knew concluded
[Music]
it wasn't even an inclusion it was taken
as a fact of life
but the difference between the
differences between the north and the
south where
there were really illusory when the
chips were down but um
they had different techniques of
castrating you there and they had them
off but the character of the castration
remained exactly the same and that was
the intention
in both places
and
furthermore is impossible to be separate
but equal
it um because equal why must you be
separate
and let's see
is that it's that
it's history that that doctrine which is
created
almost almost all of the negro's despair
author and civil rights activist james
baldwin interviewed by author and poet
robert penn warren in 1964.
and also the country's despair
so i think that the instinct to destroy
that doctrine is quite sound
you know separately yes that's right
it is it's really an attack on the white
man's assumption that um he knows more
about you than you do
he and then he knows what's best for you
and that he can you keep you in your
place
for your own good also for his own
profit ships in the ground a moment the
separate but equal or the white man
knowing best
of course you read irving howe's peace
and dissent about you and ralph
no i didn't know it's a nurse
but i heard about it
all right i have them all on my desk but
i haven't had time to read anything
i'd like to
ask you a little bit about that
well
called in passing uh every house a
billboard that can give you the best
ralph's place
[Music]
well i haven't read the pieces
yeah
i think i can imagine some of the things
with that you know
there's a ten i'm not
a great many of the negro's friends put
it that way
unconsciously to really and really
unconsciously you know no it's not meant
they don't mean to say the things they
say
there's an unconscious assumption that
somehow you know if you don't fit into
if you don't take this role to do this
or act this way
or feel this way that you have somehow
well you
betrayed something what you betrayed is
their image of you
then of course and then of course when
you when the black man realizes that
he's furious
that's exactly the point isn't wrong but
you and ralph have betrayed uh richard
wright that's the point we betrayed
richard yes how well you want to be
honest instead of keeping angry enough
you know
ralph is as angry as anybody you know
can be and still live and so am i
but
you're out in the same boat as you
betrayed the trust you say
and uh well who's irving
that's ralph's boy
that's quick back to the bilbo story
i myself don't feel that i betrayed
richard and i and i
and i still don't feel that ralph has
and first of all don't know how we do it
which is you know richard's achievement
is richard's achievement
and we every right in the world disagree
with him he may be right the world try
to go further than he
in fact we have every duty to do that
and if that offends irving howell it's
just too bad for everyone
how would you did you feel about the uh
something of the morning news or
saturday
[Music]
of the complicated tango
which you have
on any acp suit
about construction and jumping in jumps
you know to stop construction
by a strange series of
ironies the judge who
uh passes on signs the
rejection
the negro judge in the state supreme
[Music]
but it makes a strange uh situation
doesn't it
yes but um
it doesn't seem strange to me as it
might seem no to you
i don't think it's a judge
the man is a judge he's a judge a judge
is a judge read the law
speculating about those psychological
effects for both negroes and whites
[Music]
that sort of keeps me awake at night
it's um
it's really the subject of a novel which
is very dimly
very you know in my head
i don't know what that i really don't
know what that means i just have to sort
of beg off because
that gets that gets us into the whole
realm of i don't know
our politics and
private lives of people and you know and
it is also
a fantastic assault on the whole idea of
race no of the whole myth that negroes
and whites
are different no he's pretty low
and that's funny that's what he has to
do you know he's like
hard names for that of course of course
but that's
they should i think i think so i think
so too yes
i think so too i'll take the case in the
supreme court where they've descended
sending the sending justices
black and douglas and two others who uh
were out to protect uh
uh
president governor johnson the
mississippi and uh old ross barnett
federal court by the uh the jury trial
you get the four
james baldwin in 1964.
oh i just really
same situation just taking a quote from
um
again last book i've read
well forced integration of a force for
positive causes that is a busting back
by edict about about voids and things
shifts by force
uh any shift by force to make racial
balance
threatens to reduce the
individual to an integer
be shuffled about by any authority
without reference to any preferences
there may be circumstances under which
it is necessary
[Music]
but those who advocate
usually show no awareness
[Music]
but what this
what means this does not change the
roots of praises and uh
or
has other repercussions in principle
and society yeah
well what that comes to is they're going
to be very dangerous moment in this um
struggle with which one will have to
avoid if it's at all possible creating
certain very dangerous precedents that's
the idea that is uh that is
yes that is the trickiest element i
think about in the entire revolution if
that is what it is
because when will that and one has got
to be reconciled i think and under such
stress
to make to do very dangerous things and
then try to prevent them from having the
repercussions as they might have
once got to undo 100 years work you know
in in a very short time
and will have to it will not be able to
be done
as tightly as one might wish
[Music]
it won't be tidy no
i'm gonna have to go fairly soon
[Music]
let's take one question we have a few a
minute or two left uh what is the
[Music]
responsibility
of the negro as you read
it to um
establish equality and justice
and you see some of the some of the
fight man's responsibilities are
glaringly apparent
what responsibilities
i suppose that i consider the
responsibility to be something like this
to um
i think when i had to take upon myself a
very hard responsibility which is
something you do with the morale of the
young
which is to do with a sense of their
identity a sense of their uh possible
achievements a sense of themselves
and for this i think one had to take
upon myself with the necessity of trying
to be an example to them
you know
to prove you know to prove something by
your existence
and further than that i think one has to
try to um
if you want to get at the morale then a
great many of the problems would be
minim would you minimize the problem for
example the school dropouts were talking
about before the of
delinquency the problem which are all
the problems of despair demoralization
then i suppose one has to say do things
like jessie gray is doing in harlem
which is to globalize the people less
not less scenario attacks than landlords
really has to give the negro people a
sense of what they what they can do for
themselves
which is the bottom reason as i read it
the bottom purpose of the rent strike
because if one can bring this off
then there are several other things that
one might be able to think of doing part
of the problem of being a negro in this
country is that one has been
beaten so long
and been helpless along one tends to
think of oneself as being helpless
so i think the probably the primary
responsibility would be i suppose to
convey to the people whom when sort of
helplessly represents
the fact that they are not helpless
[Music]
and if they are not and that if they are
not helpless and they must try to be
responsible
and to create a leadership out of these
boys and girls in the streets which
indeed is happening they're doing it
themselves
i think it's our responsibility as their
elders
to to bear witness to them and to um
to take risks with to to take their risk
with them and because if they don't
trust their elders then we then we're
then we're in trouble
in real great trouble too
this is what it's something like that is
the way it looks to me
well i'm going to ask a question how it
has probably has no answer
and i see some of the fuzziness of the
question right away
how many negroes read your books
[Music]
well it's it's hard
how many subjects read your book
yeah it's an impossible question to
answer but i do know this my
my brother
who lives in harlem says that
the [ __ ] and junkies and people like
that steal the books and sell them in
bars
which is a
there have been a lot of hot things sold
in holland bars but i've never heard of
hot books being called halifax before
so i guess that means something
how do you feel about audience
this is a stupid question because i know
what i think i know what any writer
feels about audience
i think
well you don't think of it
just don't think of it then
no we just hope whatever you do finds
its own audience so let me take a long
long time
novelist playwright and poet james
baldwin interviewed by pulitzer prize
winning author and poet robert penn
warren on april 27 1964.
and now part two of our look back at the
american civil rights movement on this
50th anniversary year of the birmingham
campaign
this with an interview with vernon
jordan mr jordan is an attorney business
executive and was an adviser to
president clinton he grew up in atlanta
during the 1950s and graduated from
depauw university in 1957 earning a law
degree from howard university in 1960 in
1961 he and two other atlanta attorneys
sued the university of georgia alleging
racially biased admission policies that
suit resulted in a federal court order
directing the school to admit two
african-american students and mr jordan
received national attention when he
escorted those students into the
admissions office through a mob of white
students
in 1962 mr jordan was appointed georgia
field director for the naacp and led a
boycott of augusta georgia merchants who
refused to serve african americans
in 1966 vernon jordan became director of
the southern regional council's voter
education project sponsoring voter
registration campaigns in 11 southern
states and conducting seminars workshops
and conferences for candidates and
office holders
in 1972 he became head of the national
urban league on may 29 1980 vernon
jordan was shot and wounded outside a
fort wayne indiana hotel by white
supremacist joseph paul franklin
then president jimmy carter visited mr
jordan while he was recovering
vernon jordan was also a friend and
advisor to president clinton serving on
his transition team in
1992. in 1997 washington washington
tonian magazine called mr jordan the
ultimate washington insider he is
currently senior managing director with
lazar ferris and company an investment
banking firm
the interview you're about to hear is
part of the robert penn warren civil
rights oral history collection at the
university of kentucky mr penn warden
warren recorded this as research for his
book who speaks for the negro published
in 1965.
and now robert penn warren and vernon
jordan recorded in 1964 on c-span radio
at w-c-s-p-f-m washington i
received
letters of invitation from every
greek leather fraternity on the depaul
campus
fraternities were given this list of
prospective students
without regard to race
they wrote me inviting me up for dances
assuring me that
if i would come up for the weekend that
i could have a date uh
ironically there were no negro careers
on the depaul campus
and
i know that had uh
shown up on the depart campus that uh
that would have been a great
consternation
uh
the monon railroad station or at the bus
station that uh
that this fella vernon jordan turned out
to be a negro and it would have created
some problems for the fraternity uh
uh inviting me however i did not go but
i did go
i did not go for the fraternity weekends
but i did go to depaul to attend a
educational guidance clinic
is sponsored by the admissions
department in cooperation with the uh
psychology department and other
departments in the school
well
i along with
or maybe 60 other prospective college
students uh
spent a week
finding out what college was all about
uh taking the examination there's
examinations that one usually takes
as a part of the college orientation
program
it was there that i
became quite disconcerted that here
berlin jordan uh
third in his class uh
young man who felt that he'd been
everywhere i've seen everything and knew
everybody
all of a sudden i found out that on the
basis of my
tests
that i couldn't read
and uh
i was reading uh less than 200 words a
minute
and my counselor at the guidance clinic
suggested that uh
i would probably do very well with the
state supported school
but he wasn't sure as to how well i
would do uh in a private school
and suggested that do i was accepted
that i might even consider going to a
state school
or that i would probably do all right
and at depaul if i took a reading course
so i returned home and
took a reading course at atlanta
university
uh it was that time that i experienced
uh some little problem with my parents
and that having indicated to them that i
wanted to go to depaul
and i indicated this to them and despite
the fact that i have been told that it
depart that
my social life would be somewhat limited
and that there were no negro girls and
the dating of white girls was taboo
i'd also been told that
i'd have to go 40 miles to indianapolis
to get my hair cut because uh
negroes weren't permitted to get their
haircuts in downtown greencastle
i did not know at the time that uh
the most popular barber in green castle
was a negro who
ultimately would not cut my hair because
i was negro
and he told me this in the presence of
well while he was cutting a
white student's hair he told you mr boba
told you this well the barber told me
this after i went to depauw and uh
my hair got long and i
sought out a barber
and
upper classmate of mine the negro uh
and i went into uh
barney's barbershop i burned his
barbershop as i remember
and uh that's that uh
white boy in the chair a negro barber
i'd come from a segregated society where
negroes had always cut my hair so this
was commonplace with me and i said to
him uh
come in to see if i can get a haircut
and bernie said to me well i'm sorry but
uh
or in effect he said i don't cut color
folks head
or this for me was uh kind of he's on
the shop or is he an employee
he owned the shop it was a shop that he
had inherited from his father
uh
he'd been cutting hair in green castle
uh 20 years before i got there
and
bernie said to me no i can't cut your
hand
and i can't cut your hair
he said this in effect because your
color
and uh
my first reaction was to
push bernie through the window
i didn't push bernie through the one
that
i just said
thank you and
left
[Music]
with a great sense of embarrassment and
hurt
uh
it was just something i never
experienced before negro telling me
while he's cutting a white man's head
that he can't cut my hair because he's
because i'm negro
this was a pretty bad experience at any
rate uh
i suffered through that and uh do you
think attorney and civil rights activist
vernon jordan being interviewed by
robert penn warren in 1964
i don't no i don't think that bernie god
rest his soul uh
suffered through that at all uh
i think that bernie uh
uh felt that he had to do this uh
to placate uh
his white clientele bernie was the best
at that time the white boys at depaul
were wearing crew cuts crew cuts were
very popular
bernie was the best bob in town
uh
uh all the vast majority of students
went to bernie for their haircuts
but also the better of the more elite
businessmen in green castle
uh went to bernie uh the students have
told bernie to make them make a
difference whose hair he cut
just we gave them a good crew cut
but bernie felt some
fidelity a loyalty to these students and
he just refused to cut negro's hair
the bulk of his business was student
business because bernie closed his shop
in the summer
when students were away from town away
from the campus
they would only go to his shop upon
request
of the local businessman in town who
depended upon bernie as they had
depended upon his father
to cut their hair
uh
all this i told to my parents uh
and then one day i went home from
my part-time job during the summer and
found a note on my bed where
my mother says to me very sweetly uh
vernon we love you and we want you to go
to college where you want to go to
college but uh
we kind of feel like if you uh
if you went to howard university
predominantly negro school in washington
dc that
academically economically and socially
you you might be happier
but you uh you go where you want to go
and i took them at their word and chose
to go to depaul
what were their reasons
for
trying to steer you from depaul
well i i think that uh here were
negro parents
both from rural communities in georgia
both of whom
had grandparents who were slaves who
were
to some extent conditioned
to the southern way of life and
were never quite
accustomed
i could never quite adjust to the
thought of their boy
being even in green castle indiana
the only negro in the class of 400
students
and they felt that uh their boy their
baby
their their prize
uh
would would be happier and would have
less frustrations if he went to a
predominantly uh
negro institution
they just felt that
he'd get along better
and that they would have
less problems and fewer problems with
him and he'd have less problems and
fewer problems with his
peers
or if he went to an all negro school i
i should never forget
my father who
on an occasion when i had
brought a white boy from north carolina
home with me
and i forget bob's first name but uh bob
drove home with me and uh
another white boy from
dublin georgia
and he couldn't get a bus out that night
so he spent the night with me and uh
he slept in one twin bed and my brother
was away at school and i slept in
another
and in the middle of the night
my father
got up out of bed and came in the room
and caught on the light
and
stood there with tears in his eyes and
cut the light out and went back to the
bed and
and said to my mother that uh
you know uh this democracy thing is
really here
and uh it's right here in my house
uh
there in one bed is my it's my own son
and
in the other bed is a white boy from
south carolina
with a sharp southern accent
who says yes sir no sir
and who eats grits
with the same enjoyment as my boy
who likes biscuits and who likes sausage
and says to me
a colored man
yes sir no sir
and says to my wife yes ma'am and no
ma'am
this for my
my father was a
traumatic experience could you analyze
the experience
well uh i'm back on it well yeah
i think that here again you have to look
at
this man's background
he was one of 17 children
the father my father yes uh
from uh
on the worst counties in the state
jasper county georgia that's monticello
uh he had heard
stories of people being lynched uh
i'm not so sure that he had
not seen the results of uh
brutalities
uh
there in jasper county
who left home with a circus
because
he worked from sun up to sundown
his daddy got all the money
who was a boy
a family of 17 children uh
saw the entire family divide a
watermelon when the mom and papa took
one half and the 17 children divided the
other half
a boy who never knew that the
chicken had anything but feet
or necks
until such time that he got
enough money to buy his own chicken
and uh
he left home out of a great sense of
disillusionment and disappointment
and uh
really in a sense out of rebelliousness
to the system
under which his father found
accommodating and uh
and the way of life in jasper county
georgia
i think that uh somewhere during that
night
after having had dinner and
conversations with this white boy from
south carolina
who
seemed to have been a good friend of his
sons
i gather he was a
decent well-minded white boy
welcome
very well mannered uh
a boy who was uh
not completely void of prejudices i'm
not so sure that that i could have gone
to his house and spent the night
attorney and civil rights activist
vernon jordan interviewed by robert penn
warren and i'm sure that this uh
to some extent uh
uh bothered him
that uh here is this negro boy from
georgia who can extend to me these
courtesies but uh
i'm not so sure that i would see receive
the warmth and
kindredness of
of
i'm not sure that
this warmth will be extended to him and
my household
i think that bob felt that uh
i'm not very certain that i could
even
approach my parents with the idea
of bringing a negro home i'm not even
sure that he
told his folks
uh
that he has spent a night with vernon
jordan a colored boy who's in school
with him up there
uh
i can't say this with any certainty this
is just a kind of feeling that i had
at any rate
against the
mild objection to my parents i went on
to greencastle
my parents took me to school
along with my
uh younger brother
uh
we all drove to green castle and
we did everything that the little
brochure says from
go to the tent on the other side of
goldberg church on it on the depaul
campus
we were assigned
housing my parents stayed with the local
methodist minister
elma harvey who was very charming and
very gracious and i think that this
ended of itself was a
real experience for my parents
my father who
was a government employee in mail
service
my mother who uh
paid my tuition
by making food tasty and pretty as a
caterers
and it always been in
a domestic role
this i think for them was
was a real experience certainly it was
unique and different
but they
took me and they left me and i should
never forget
my dad is standing out of in front of
old lease college uh
saying goodbye saying uh to me son uh
uh
you know everybody is looking for you to
to do well
and uh
certainly i expect more of you than
than they do and i
i feel like you're gonna do all right
and i'm glad you're here i think that
after they got to the depaul campus
after they experienced the
the friendliness the warmth of the
campus
and the uh
open
kindredness of the people
that they were satisfied that
their boy had made a good choice
and that uh they had to read him right
it reared him to uh to do the right
thing to think uh pretty much the right
thing to
to conduct himself like
like a gentleman and they were
reasonably certain that he would do all
right in this atmosphere
and i think they left they came to green
castle that weekend curious and
concerned and to some extent worried
but i think they left satisfied that
their boy
doing a situation totally foreign to him
a situation where he was the only negro
in this class
one of five negroes and a student body
of
of five thousand one who would have to
live with
two white boys whom he never seen before
i think they left uh
going back down highway 41 confident
that
all would be well
and that
that boy would
would do all right
they also left confident that though
there might be
some small financial strain or something
that
the dare boy
they could pay his bills
and uh
and they did they did it
he paid him in advance
his tuition was never late
and he never had to be concerned as to
whether or not
his funds were forthcoming
his only job was to was to get his
lessons
uh i started off
uh
struggling behind i took reading for
four semesters
uh i should never forget in a speech
course
and i took speech
speech was recommended to me through my
faculty advisor
because i'd won several article contests
in high school so i took some advanced
speech
course and i was really at a loss
because in this speech course my
classmates talked about plays that they
had done
books that they'd read
i was somewhat at a loss because the
whole time i was in high school
i never really read a full novel and my
first my first novel uh
was a may of caster bridge
or thomas hardy
and i'm not sure that's a good book for
anybody to get started on it's full of
pessimism uh
but that was my first novel though
and i think that
early
in that speech class
i realized well
that my
segregated education had been inadequate
and not only about segregated education
but my southern education
was somewhat inadequate for me to to
cope with
the academic problems i faced as a
school that uh
as good as depaul well let me let me say
this
as i see the revolution
the revolution is
a revolution
fought
number one not to take over
but it is a revolution one difference
yes
no liquidation that's right that's right
but it's a revolution
wherein you
assume
or that you take unto yourself
not anything superior not anything
less than uh uh
what is already given but you assume it
you assume some equal stature
or equal recognition
or equal opportunity or equal chance
this is not to say that uh
you're gonna hog the show
but this is to say that if two apples
are being passed out that you're gonna
get your two apples right alongside the
next fella and that because you are uh
negro
that you necessarily are limited to
a half apple
and i think that this is what the
revolution is about
is that
a half a loaf
or 99
uh
is not enough that you got to have
uh uh all of it
uh in terms of your equal share
uh
or in terms of your share
and uh
what goes on and the opportunities and
and then the uh
the privileges of that and and also with
this
the rights and privileges that you also
share in the responsibilities
civil rights activist vernon jordan
interviewed by poet and author robert
penn warren in 1964 on c-span radio this
does not conform
to any previous
uh social movement as far as i can make
out it's not has no parallel
in anything in history i i inclined to
believe i don't want to be dogmatic
about that this is me
now you may say therefore it's not a
revolution that is a word
but i'll follow you alive this is this
is not at all like any
revolutionary events ever cut before
yeah
it doesn't aim for liquidation of a
class or group of people
only for a change of idea
is that right and
a change of idea
and and
a change of status
from one of the number two
to an equal place and that uh
and and moving into this you do not
usurp
anything that the people who already
have these rights happening what is this
be said to be the first democratic
revolutions to the world
yeah uh uh uh i'm not sure i'm in a
position to substantiate it
but i do think that the most important
thing about this revolution is that
it is not a revolution
geared to liquidate as you use
it's not a revolution that
the build street barricades it's not the
revolutions fought with arms
uh
uh
but it's a it's a revolution i think uh
uh
it operates on a very human level
whereby you try to uh
to get people to do things on the basis
of people of people
well uh going back then this could seem
to be the first
uh democratic revolution that's ever
existed
by this definition
where it's not aiming to liquidate a
class or regime
but admit it to uh
reinterpret the life of a whole society
that's right there
uh
overthrow was a good word
that
some people in southern said they're
trying to overthrow us
[Music]
but i think that
this thing is uh
a matter of presently the white man
being in the in the driver's seat and
saying g and hall
pulling both rings but here's a negro
who's saying let me two get up in the
right in the driver's seat and let me
have something to say about which way
this horse is going to ge of which way
he's gone
the white man
you are talking about
[Music]
misinterprets
the whole uh movement man right that's
right
i think this is part of true expression
inside he doesn't understand
that uh uh when a negro
gains this right of first-class
citizenship he doesn't understand that
that when the negro gains this that he
does not lose anything right now
he doesn't lose anything
uh uh because you can't lose that which
you uh
uh in a sense don't have a right to
exclusively he does not conceive
[Music]
of the nature
of this revolution he thinks the same as
a previous revolution if we call this
iran what is it called yeah this
revolution is not a coup uh
it's not a power grab put it that way
that's right that's right now
undoubtedly i think we must admit this
for some negroes it is
but i think that even those negroes
but this is a myth
it seems to me yeah those people are
outside the actual actual social
yes
yes
but somebody is clearly i mean everybody
has vengeances
and there was uh some uh
vindictiveness uh involved in this uh i
think that vindicators say
some people would say in anonymizing
revolutions
of the past they would say there are two
dynamic forces in a revolution
hope and hate
your care revolution until you have the
hope for change
and some guarantee of our success
that purely beaten down can only have a
serve out of which leads nowhere
the revolution means a dynamic hope or a
shame that's
invisible
plus
a hate
now here
i think you have to address yours have
to hate her foot
and i think all right
go ahead
well i think it has to be a hate of what
whether it's a hate
uh
of the system
or whether it's a hate of the people who
perpetuate the system all right now we
have a distinction which has never been
made before in any revolution
it's the first time all of the force bit
of the perpetuator is not on the thing
perpetuated yes
and i think that this revolution
uh if you're going to use the word hate
hate here must be used
as
as as hating
that they
not to perpetuate us but that which is
perpetuated uh uh the system itself
uh because i think
to hate those people in power those
people who perpetuate uh
would lead to
the overthrow or the liquidation now
necessary
well you are now uh talking like
dr king
well i don't mind talking like dr king
i'm not saying there's an affront to you
at all i'm just saying you are yeah but
now because
i think you also ought to understand
that uh
personally uh i'm not out to redeem the
soul of america either
well could you do it just in passing
perhaps
well i think that uh uh
you see i take the position that
when i exercise my constitutional right
uh
i don't care how
the man sitting at the neck table next
to me feels about it or whether my
presence that changes his heart or not
i don't give a damn if he regurgitates
or if he gets up and leaves
or
if he turns over his glass or spills his
coffee on the waitress
that's his problem wouldn't you have a
slight preference that matter
well
uh
there's nothing like eating your meal
sort of uh
and and some quiet to
some tranquil uh situation but by the
same token uh
this man is uneasy
if he if he gets ants in his pants
that's his problem and it only becomes
my problem at such time that he comes
and stands over me
or disturbs me in the
peaceful or tranquil enjoyment of my
meal now
uh
by that i mean
my presence say is not good
to
to to
to redeem him
uh
uh it's not good to redeem him to love
me or to to
to to think well of me
but i also feel
that if i sit next to him in the
classroom long enough
or that if i
select him on an airplane
long enough there's somewhere along the
way
he's going to come to the same
realization that my classmates came to
who had to live with me
uh without that consent that this guy uh
he's just another guy
that uh he has uh basically he does many
of the same things that we do
but uh
he doesn't like asparagus and i don't
like brussels sprouts well how
different are you from dr kingman
well i i think that dr king's philosophy
is
is such that
through this uh
uh creative uh
suffering i think he he calls it uh
that uh you you
you reach out and
and you make this man love
civil rights activist vernon jordan
interviewed in 1964. you cultivate uh
because i i'm not
i've never been quite sure what it means
about love because when he talks about
this love he says that
i can assure you that you can't like
everybody
well uh
i agree with him on that a lot of folks
white black i don't like a lot of folks
fighting back i don't want to live next
door to a lot of folks fighting back out
the one in my house for dinner or
collecting my bills or anything else so
i have no problem with that but
uh
this business of
of redeeming the soul
and i guess this is through some sort of
spiritual revelation
as to the goodness and to the to the
uh uh
some sort of perfect situation where the
negro is concerned i'm not interested in
that
uh when i send my child to school or
when i go to school
or when i use a public conveyance
when i pay my taxes i just don't want
anybody to disturb me in the free
exercise of my constitutional rights now
how he feels
as he sees me exercising is right it's
his problem
tell me this suppose we had
all our mothers uh constitutional rights
clearly defying kelly
civil rights constitutional rights
what remains
well
i think if you had to say clear
as a result of this clarity
control
controlled by what by the law itself by
the operation of the law to say that
when this man comes to register to vote
that you cannot
impose upon him arbitrary standards
because he's black
that
that when you get these kind of things
dissipated
that somehow or other as this negro
operates freely
in this situation
that even the most prejudiced white man
will will come to see as he sees him
operating freely this has been his
problem he's already seen him operate
under a given set of circumstances
and can only appreciate him for him
acting
under this given set of circumstances
uh dictated by custom or raising usage
but when he sees him acting as a free
agent
and at that time he will
come to i believe
ultimately
some appreciation this person
not as a black man but as an individual
as you're putting your faith then
in
a legal uh framework which allows the
human
free play after that that's right that's
right and and once you get this free
play once you get this intercourse
once you find that when you sit next to
this man that uh
uh
he reads the newspaper
that he's tired on the bus going home
that he's answers to get home to his
wife and uh in a warm bowl of stew just
like you are
did you find his similarities
you find his similarity of hope
to some extent similarity of despair
uh uh
and these are common bonds this is the
human communion you put your trust in
that that's right once the legal
framework itself that's right but now
until such time
that the bus driver
knows that it's illegal for him to crack
me across my head
or that he does not have the sanction of
the state
to hit me across america i sit on the
front seat and we can never reach this
point of human communion because he
always sees me in a uh
in a servile
with a different situation he just sees
me uh
he cannot see me as i really am
but he sees me in a condition imposed
upon me by extensive circumstances what
happened in germany and i don't answer
this
i hope you don't expect me to tell you
in the late 20s
about the jews
who had total legal protection and and
apparently uh
poor participation
in a society or very of all practical
standards
well
i think that you have to look at the
leadership there a man who
will take these certain group of people
and exploit them uh
because of their
their religious difference
that was a small matter that wasn't
something else was involved
religion was just something
he had different differences yes
yes yes here were some people different
and if i attack them on the basis of
that difference then i can ride the
crest of power let me ask if the
question is shifting around a little bit
when james baldwin writes
at the southern mob there's a street
gang you know
all the cops in jackson
act as they act
they do not represent
the will of the southern majority
that make sense
well it makes sense uh
and that
i believe the vast majority of
southern's for southern twice others for
some reason or other
uh
would be reluctant
to be identified with this lunatic
friends
and i also believe this
that you got
on one extreme maybe twenty percent of
the people who are totally opposed to it
the other side this the other twenties
opposed to the mob and the practice of
the mob this kind of thing
uh
and who also believe uh
in the
complete equality and freedom of the
negro and then you have the other 20
percent that composes the mob but then
you have a 60
who uh will go pretty much the way
that the populace goes that so long as
it does not involve them
having to make a
a personal witness civil rights activist
vernon jordan interviewed by robert penn
warren in 1964. uh uh
a testimony
uh
and this is why i think leadership is so
very important there's no leadership in
the south now except for the
uh segregationists is that
no real leadership
well that's something a little funny but
there's no no no fundamental energy
because i think that the real
fundamental leadership is silent
and and the people
that's right that's right that's right
and their silence uh
makes them uh uh ineffective
and once you can give uh
once a guy like chuck morgan in
birmingham
vocalizes
uh and this takes an awful lot of
courage and it ultimately resulted in
chuck's having to leave birmingham
and it takes a great deal of courage
because what the man is faced with or
what he thinks he's faced with is a very
bread and butter matter
uh he is a lawyer who must necessarily
depend upon white clients uh
for business
and this business depends upon his house
mortgage or or his house mortgage and
the grocery bill depend upon the
business he's got considerations and i
think maybe if you can dispel these
fears uh uh you can get more people to
act now what happened to this uh
the splintering of the present-day negro
leadership in atlanta and elsewhere then
the problem of uh control and unity in
negro
well
i i think that
as in most situations uh
young people
as they become more exposed to
to education educational opportunities
uh
as they become more aware of what's
going on in their society
and as they attempt to
to project themselves to project their
ideas
there i think it's kind of a natural
there's a natural repudiation on the
part of the whole of people who have
been in power for so long
that they think that young folk ought to
wait their turn
you were talking this morning of your
participation in summit conference in
atlanta
uh last year yes before the uh
the distributors in the city ends here
yes
and
you diagnosed for me
the
basic splits in the summit uh group can
you do that again please yes well i
think that uh basically in the uh
atlanta summit uh
leadership conference uh
that you have three basic groups you
have the
the the direct actionist
those people who feel that
demonstrations per se
uh
are necessary not only to dramatize the
situation but to shape
the so-called power structure out of its
apathy and out of its intransigence
and out of its adamancy uh
with regard to the status quo
i think also that there is a
second group the the moderates who
believe in selective
direct action who believe in
concerted direct action at a at a
particular target at such that at such
time that
negotiation with that particular target
with the people who control that
particular target has failed i think
also that these uh moderates believe in
uh
prior to
an onslaught of demonstrations or direct
action they believe in taking the
approach of discussing first what the
problem is with the people involved
uh uh
a sort of sustained process of
negotiation and what have you and then
at this time that that has failed
then i think they would take the
position that negotiations are the only
way to starvation let me ask a question
here a second group democrats
are they moving in terms of limited
objectives each time is that the idea
yes i think they take the position that
uh
that uh that's right that
none of these situations are
all or nothing
that uh that you might have to make a
concession here but this concession here
is necessary so that you might uh be
able to move on another front
necessarily that uh you cannot
in your
petition
ask for everything necessarily but that
you it is important that you concentrate
on
a target until such time as you
completed this and then you move to b
uh
now thirdly i think the third group
which would be the established
leadership
put some faith
in the conference table
uh everything can be worked out
and i think that they use the term
worked out because over the years things
have been worked out
and generally they've been worked out
not necessarily to the
disadvantage of the negro but
oftentimes they have uh
get themselves to to maintain things as
a
as uh
on a status quo basis fernand jordan
attorney and civil rights activist
interviewed by author and poet robert
penn 1964.
i think that the magic of the
whole thing is to
find some formula whereby you you
you give it to each of the uh
uh
procedures
of
of of the of the three groups i think
maybe there's room for
for all of these things to operate but i
think that you have to assess it
like a quarterback
says he's moving his team towards the
goal line
uh roy wilkins made some reference to
this uh in his speech to the annual
dental southern region council there are
times when it's appropriate for the
quarterback to do a quarterback sneak at
other times needs to kick on third down
uh
but it does not mean necessarily he
would uh
heal a field goal from his own two yard
line uh who are the people and uh which
organizations
are identified in the summit uh
conference with these three positions
how do you learn them are the persons of
all the patients have continued three
positions well i think that uh jim
fulman
who's the executive director of student
nonviolent coordinating committee
uh
would stand out as the leader
of the action group
uh the first group that i mentioned
he's joined in that group by the uh
committee on appeal for human rights
who's presently led by a young fellow
named ladder fox the student of morris
college
uh the student
house college
uh the committee on appeal for human
rights uh
uh is a continuation of the
student coalition of schools here
that uh led to
the city ends of 1960.
i don't think that the committee on
appeal
has
the kind of creative and imaginative
leadership that uh it's firstly just had
uh i think that there's still to stay
suffer some frustration
from what their
older brothers or their
classmates in high school who were year
to ahead of them did and
they too want to join the crusade but i
think they they have not quite realized
that the situation in 1964 or 1963 is
not as it was in 1960 and the novelty of
the cities is not the same or the
uniqueness of the cities is not the same
in 1963-64
they were
in uh
1960
and i think that
your moderate leadership in atlanta
would come from
think that you would really have to put
the sclc
uh for the christian leadership
conference to some extent
though not wholeheartedly in the uh
group with a direct actionist what about
any with which you who are associated
well i think the naacp here is uh
uh
pretty much the
would have to be classed in a moderate
group
they did here advocate uh the
sacrificial easter
egg boycott for easter uh as an
appropriate uh direct action technique
but i think that for all practical
purposes at the
local branching acp here under the
leadership of dr seymour smith
would have to be classed as a
uh uh is moderate in this classification
as would the uh
the urban league uh
clarence coleman who's the co-chairman
of the southern conference now
and also director of the southern region
area for the
uh comprising several states in the
south american national
i think that they too would have to be
classed as moderates now i would put uh
the atlanta negro voters league
which historically in atlanta has been a
very powerful influence i think we would
have to class him uh as a part of the
established leadership
uh led by walden or c scott of the
the editor of the atlantic in the world
who believe that uh if you go
to the white people
and sit down and talk with them that
these things can be worked out i think
however also that uh they have come to
realize that
that this uh is not enough
it uh it takes more
and uh this is not talking to get the
kind of results
now the one thing i one area you've
heard i think that the summer leadership
has failed that is
there's been some play here to realize
that their power potential
oh certainly if they realize it uh
to to implement this realization
and and
into the
mobilization of the real political power
and political strength
of negroes in this town
you have an all citizens registration
committee which does
registration and voting but uh
registration and voting
uh in the negro community has never been
a completely
total lingering project
uh
preach about it people talk about it uh
and and and but uh it has never been a
total uh
and i'm sure that this has not been
achieved in many many other communities
what about the thing you mentioned this
morning about the split in the
uh summit
uh conference
that uh mr walker rod walker
uh had a memorandum a white
a little bloodshed to point things up
yeah well why walker my good friend the
one whom i have most respect for but one
whom i deserved right to disagree with
uh in his baton plan uh uh
uh had something to the effect that uh
uh
we need to create an incident
and uh we need to show the policemen to
be exactly what they are
bad and mean and evil
and there was something in his plan
whereby there's a need to
deliberately provoke them into action
revoke a negro policeman into action
against negro no no no no no no this is
this i'm sure this is not does not
relate to the negro police
uh this is a part of the astuteness of
the local police force here chief
jenkins uh he was a
chief of the police force here too
thinking that uh
the use of negro officers
would have some disconcerting effect on
the demonstrators that uh they might not
act quite as bad uh whether this proved
to be true
another position to say civil rights
activist vernon jordan interviewed in
1964 by robert penn warren on c-span
radio
doesn't it
well it sounds difficult to raise the
issue of police brutality
because i think that uh
by nature
the
negro policemen are in sympathy with
what the liberal demonstrators are doing
about the same token they have their
responsibility
uh to do that duty
and uh if giving orders to rest they
have some responsibility to do just that
just that
but no wrapping
of course up and uh
uh
i doubt seriously if you find uh
any real instances of negro policemen
roughing up demonstrators
did you find the this is his
white policeman dropping up
demonstrators in this uh
last file there were reported instances
i cannot uh test one way or the other as
to the accuracy of these instances
because
i did not see them
i think that
only those persons who were present uh
could attest to that
i conspicuously however that
their presence of negroes uh attacking
the systems
could engender some sort of uh
retired or efforts on the part of white
policemen
uh
if
any random exist to provoke
some rockingham
isn't it likely that somebody always
owens provoking and wrapping up
i think apart
isn't it that you have a policy uh for
poking wrapping up uh has been discussed
that you may very well find some
individual provokings and roughing up
even against himself
i think so uh
it ain't provoked as a part of
well i think it's deliberate and i think
that this is an error
i think that uh
uh
the protest uh is enough that you don't
have to deliberately
uh
provoke policemen to do
often times things that they might want
to do but would not do uh by exercising
some restraint
on normal circumstances and i think you
push them
now uh
it needs to be pointed out that uh but i
think that the demonstrators saw the
fallacy of this position
of
deliberately provoking the police
and
there were indications that they had
refrained from so doing
how serious
and what i mean with the word serious
here
but how serious uh is the budgets
of you
the fractures
uh not merely in the
atlanta conference with a negro
leadership in general
how much of a problem is this
well
uh
i don't see it as as as a terrible
problem because i think that
no group or organization
as in the monopoly on the panacea
i think that each group can show where
uh
its particular method or is particularly
emphasizing method has worked in a given
situation
i think the problem that the civil
rights organizations have
is out of assessing a particular
situation for exactly what it is
and on the basis of that assessment
determine
what is the appropriate action uh
that can possibly bring about the
the quickest possible result that being
desegregation human nature being what it
is
isn't um
they are bound to be an element of mere
struggle for power to in all these
matters
uh i should think that uh you can never
uh
subtract
the
the
the glitter aspect of it
or the struggle for power or to struggle
to to take credit
for focal back which has been
accomplished and i'm not sure that this
is not healthy
uh
that's right people are people
and uh
people want credit uh oftentimes people
won't credit when they're not uh do it
and
i just know what you do what you do
about the situation is quite human and
uh
uh likely to recur again and again
there's one thing
speaking historically
always as far as i know
in
revolutionary situations
the leader the single man has emerged
has taken charge pulitzer prize-winning
poet and author robert penn warren
he's dominated the scene
now there is no single
man who has emerged
to dominate
control be the focus of
of the negro movement
getting that general term rather than
civil rights the general general focus
for
uh
negro revolt resistance unrest i just
used to call it
the newest person is martin luther king
that's right but he is far from having
uh uh an undivided support
well i think there's no unanimity
necessarily
uh but i think that even those people
who would disagree with dr king's
method of operating will acknowledge
that he is a titular head of the rights
party so to speak civil rights activist
vernon jordan this took place in 1964.
and i think that the negro movement has
historically had a
one person who was at rallying cry
a frederick druglist on the abolitionist
time
and in the postwar
civil period
uh
you had two people to rise uh to
national prominence prominence
immediately following the turn of the
century the boys and and and and book of
washington where you had conflict and
views
uh and then following the boys and and
uh
washington certainly there it was james
weldon johnson who served for a long
time as executive secretary nacp
and uh
that rising in the late 30s was charlie
houston
uh
who was really the brain trust of the
susan under the 14th amendment
and during the war walter white who was
a rallying cry
and after walter white thurgood marshall
and um
randolph historically uh uh is uh is
considered even today i think the l and
d is in my opinion the older statesman
of the
of the movement uh but
now here's a moment of
what appears to be decisive conflict
and the
vocal leader has not emerged
[Music]
this may be another different from all
previous
such movements
but the resistance to dr king is very
great in some quarters as we know
besides
very very well uh it's quite great uh
people stuck with him because there's
nobody else taking place but that way in
many cases uh
because in my personal opinion i think
that uh
and i think the history will prove me
brag me out
ultimately
that roy wilkins uh
was quiet uh very efficient
extremely able and capable man
uh who
in the naacp circles and
national and international is respected
as an able leader
will probably come out as one of the
unsung heroes
uh
of the negro's cause
uh
he leads and heads the largest most
powerful civil rights organization
uh
to some extent which
whose name itself perpetuates uh
a kind of head
but uh i'm not sure necessarily roy is
uh
is associated as the leader
uh i wish he were because i think that
he actually is
in my opinion i i consider roy my leader
and i consider roy more important to
civil rights movement
in many aspects than than dr king
you need to understand that
i say this because i have naacp
background had been worked on mr wilkins
staff
but
i'm not so blind as to
not be able to recognize so real value
that dr king has played in this movement
and that is a rallying negroes i think
you have to have a rallying cry
you have to have the chili the man out
front who who's going to get the crowds
in
and uh and he's going to inspire them i
think that that was very appropriate
that uh at the washington march
that dr king be last because he was a
the personification of the emancipator
that he was the moses he is the most
well i deserved the bride wrestling is
probably a good thinking a good
organizer
but uh not a leader in the true sense of
the word uh
he he's administrating the man who
implements
did you know a story which is
fairly common that he was
protected
and called the great organization march
on washington to close ranks
well i'm not terribly familiar with that
uh uh
so you came under fire there were models
charged with revives other things
and to protect him we said he is mister
march on white and he is an
indispensable organizer
cover up to protect him we would like to
prevent a uh spit on the whole program
i'm not aware of that
this is what a failed one here as you
know
i'm just not aware i understand he's a
very accomplished man with very definite
ideas also one of the things one is this
that he uh
uh
his presence in the boycott the
[Music]
[Applause]
i am not terribly disturbed
at the competition
uh
by the numerous organizations that are
not what they seem because i think that
they all have a role to play
i think that the naacp plays a major
role
i think that it is still the guardian
protect and defend of nuclear rights in
this country
that will always be
attorney and civil rights activist
vernon jordan interviewed in 1964 by
pulitzer prize-winning poet and author
robert penn warren
as we bring you this oral history
looking back at the american civil
rights movement on this 50th anniversary
year of the birmingham birmingham
campaign a series of protests against
racial segregation in the u.s
you're listening to c-span radio wcs pfm
washington available on hd radio we're
live on the web at c-spanradio.org
and xm satellite radio channel 119.
in the headlines at this hour
three south american countries now say
they are well james baldwin in his own
words
in 1979 he spoke about his experiences
as a black writer and the civil rights
movement
the speech took place at the university
of california berkeley
[Applause]
i'm going to improvise
like a writer
on some assumptions
and
though i feel a little uneasy in doing
this
and saying this
nevertheless
what a writer is obliged at some point
to realize
is that he's involved in a language
which he has to
change
for example
for a black writer
especially in this country
to be born into the english language
is to realize
that the assumptions of the language
the assumptions on which the language
operates
are his enemy
when othello kills desdemona for example
he says
i threw away a pearl
richer than all my tribe
i was very young when i read that
and i wondered about that
richer than my time
i really had to think about
being as black as sin
as black as night
black-hearted
and in order this is another story won't
go into
in order to
to deal with that really
to deal with that
at a certain time in my life when i was
not in this country but in
france
where i could not speak to anybody
because i spoke no french
but no one wanted to speak to me
i dropped into a silence
in which i heard
for the first time really heard and
began to be able to try to deal with
the beat
of the language
of the people who had produced me
i might have been able to do that here
but in the event i was not able to do it
here i did it far away
and when i was able to hear that music
because
when i was young
there were no black writers as models
and white writers columbia models either
i did not agree at all
with the moral predicament of
huckleberry finn concerning the gym
it was not i draw a question
about whether i should be sold back into
slavery
i want to
try to shift a certain assumption
i want to suggest
that instead of as we have now for far
too long according to me
instead of speaking about the civil
rights movement
which is american phrase
which i'm going to go into in a moment
which upon examination
means nothing at all
let us pretend
that i stand before you
as a witness
and let us pretend that everyone under
the sound of my voice is in the same
condition
i'm a witness to
and a survivor of
the latest slave rebellion
i put it that way
because
malcolm x and i met many years ago
when malcolm was doing a debate with a
very young sit-in student
and malcolm was a black muslim
and the radio station called me to
moderate this discussion
which i did
i was not needed
i must tell you
malcolm was
one of the most beautiful
and one of the most gentlemen
i met in all my life
you ask the boy a question
which i now present to you
if you are a citizen
why do you have to fight for your civil
rights
if you're fighting for your civil rights
that means you're not a citizen
and in fact
the legality of this country
and i won't
further investigate the word legality
has never had anything to do
with its
former slaves
we are still governed by the slave codes
now
when i say a slave rebellion
i mean that what is called the civil
rights movement
was really
insurrection
it was
co-opted
now the late j edgar hoover
is in his grave god bless him
a lot of what i knew
and many other people knew
during those years
and only a fraction of what we knew
during all those years
can now be
more or less discussed
so one can say
that the latest slave rebellion
was brutally put down
we all know
what happened to medgar
and it was not
some lunatic who happened wandering
around mississippi with a gun
the one little tick in mississippi at
that moment
happened to have a gun somewhere
and by some odd coincidence
unbelievable
shot mediga evers in the car part of his
home
in the sight and hearing
of his wife and his children
and megha was 37.
the lunatic
was carried into the front door visibly
of a nursing home
and out the back door
and that was that
we all know what happened to malcolm
we all know what happened to martin
we know what happened to fred hampton
mark clark
and so many more
honey don't tell me
i mean the list is long
that is the result of a slave rebellion
now
i'm saying that
since we are the survivors of it
since we have our children
to raise
to save
i'm saying that to say
a very brutal thing must be said
must be said
the intentions
of this melancholic country
as concerns black people
and anyone who doubts me
can ask any indian
i've always been genocidal
they needed us for labor and for sport
now
they can't get rid of us
we cannot be exiled
and they cannot be accommodated
now something's got to give
the machinery of this country
operates today in and day out
hour by hour
until this hour
to keep the [ __ ] in his place
when i was young
among other things
i used to run an elevator
murderously but i ran it
i am not needed to run the elevator no
more
a whole lot of things we used to do
they needed more no more
on the other hand
we're here
it is true
that this is going to be a difficult
summer
in every city in this nation now
black father is standing in the street
watching black sun they're watching each
other and neither one of them got no
place to go
that is not their fault
there's nothing to do with their value
their merit their capabilities
there may be nothing worse
under heaven
to
be no greater crime
than to attack
a man's integrity
to attempt to destroy that man
for i know
in spite of the american constitution
in spite
of all the born-again christians
i know
that my father
was not a mule
and not a thing
and then my sister was not born
to be the plaything
of idol white sheriffs
what am i saying i'm saying we find
ourselves
in a rock if you like in a hard place
i am saying something else
i am saying
that our presence in this country
terrifies
every white man walking
i'm going to go back and clarify that a
minute
i want to suggest
and is a very important suggestion
first of all
this is not now
never has been
and now never will be
a white country
there is not a white person in this
country
who are president to all his friends
who can prove his wife
it is absolutely true
the people who settled this country
came from
many places
and where they were
before they came here
was france
england
in france they were french
in england they were english
in italy they were italian
in greece they were greek
in russia they were russian
it's worth noting by the way
that this um
uh phenomena phenomenon called europe
has never agreed about anything
at all
except us
they don't get along until this hour
only ever unites them
the common market for example is about
us
and they can't get that together
because they're squabbling over what's
left of their colonies
in short they've lost their clowns ray
charles might put it
and this means
that we
have to consider first of all
white
malcolm said the state of mind
because i want to be misunderstood as
saying
i'm not talking about white people
insofar as you think you're white
you're irrelevant
[Applause]
we can no longer afford
that particular romance
we are all in any case here
i want to point out a paradox
the only people in this country who have
any notion of who they are
the only people in this country where
any notion of who they are
are the black people in this country
and i will tell you why
when the italian got here or the greek
or whoever
there was a moment
in his life
when he had
to start to speak english when he became
a guy named joe
and that meant he couldn't speak to his
father
because his father couldn't speak
english
that meant
a rupture
a profound rupture
so the son did become a guy named joe
and never found out anything else about
himself
we come out of a history black people in
this country come out of history which
was never written down
the connection between father and son
between mother and daughter
until this hour and in spite of the
danger which we stand and all that i
know is happening all around us every
day
we forged ourselves out of this fire
and if we could do that
and we have done that
we can deal with
what now lies before us
i know
i ain't got no jobs to give nobody
i know that
i know i ain't got no money
i can't co-opt you
[Applause]
i know
many things must be done i know
that i can't do them
but i also know
but i forgot to do them alone
we have never been alone
that's a mystery
every
white person in this country
i do not care what he says or she says
knows one thing
they may not know as they put it what i
want
but they know
they would not like to be black here
if they know that
they know everything they need to know
and whatever else they say
is a lie
bear in mind children i mean that
the american idea of progress
when the americans talk about progress
they mean
how fast i become white
that is a trick back
because they know perfectly well i can
never become white
i've drunk my share of dry martinis
i have proven myself civilized in every
way i can
[Applause]
but there is an irreducible difficulty
something doesn't work
[Applause]
well
i decided
i decided
i might as well act like a [ __ ]
[Applause]
now
the black people of this country
stand in a very strange place sort of
the white people of this country is a
very strange place
and almost for the very same reason
that we approach it from different
points of view
i pretend i suggest you think about it
that what
uh the cia for example
i use the word advisor name
for example
all the president of the united states
for example
all ambassadors except one
don't know
about the world which surrounds them
is the price they pay for not knowing me
if you couldn't deal with my father
how are you going to deal with the
people in the streets of tehran
i could have told you if anyone had
asked
[Applause]
and the fall of the shah
did not in the least astonish me
nor did it make me sad
but this means
the black people of this nation
represent
for the western powers
and for the western powers for the
moment
bearing in mind what we must do to save
our children
for the moment let us substitute the
word conspiracy
there is a reason
there is a reason
that no one wants our children until
this day educated
when we attempt ourselves to do it
we find ourselves up against the vast
machinery
of the system of education in this
country which is among other things a
billion dollar industry
and the billion dollar industry is more
important
the life of the child
[Applause]
now i want to suggest
i want everyone to think about it
i know the machinery
is vast ruthless cunning
and
thinks of nothing in fact
but itself
which means us
because
we are a threat to the machinery
we have lived through as i suggested a
slave rebellion
we cannot pick up guns
because they got the guns
you know
we cannot hit those streets again
because they're waiting for us
we have to do something else
before each lay rebellion
there was something which i now call
non-cooperation
how to execute this
in detail is something each one of us
have to figure out
but we could begin with the schools
and take our children out of those
schools
take them off those buses
everybody knows who thinks about it
that you can't change your school
without changing the neighborhood and
you can change neighborhoods without
changing the city ain't nobody prepared
to change the city because they want the
city to be white
[Applause]
all the american cities have gone to
crumble when the white people moved out
to get away from the [ __ ]
every crisis in every city is caused by
that
how can you expect the people who cannot
educate their own children
to educate anybody else
[Applause]
this will be
well contested
nevertheless
one's got to start
somewhere and i'll use that as an
example there are other things i have in
mind but i'm not really a tactician i'm
a disturber of the peace
i want you to think about it
because i know what could happen if you
do think about it
one more thing
it is you still bear in mind
this country
and indeed the west
has been living on a war economy
since 1939
it is useful to bear in mind
that we would be at war now if we could
afford to be
[Applause]
ain't no place left to go to war
all the colonies though they still
belong to europe
and no longer where they were
now it's a matter of getting the uh the
resources of the country out of europe
and european hands and african hands
and we are involved in that the black
people this country involved in that
if we this country
could afford to raise an army and afford
to go to war
it would do so
this country cannot raise an army to set
anywhere in the world which he can trust
so
we hold trump
when you try to slaughter when you try
to slaughter our people
and leave them nothing to lose
your credit is not even nothing to lose
and if i ain't got nothing to lose
what are you going to do to me
we have one thing to lose
that's our children
and we've never done that yet
after all we haven't done that yet
and there's no reason for us to do it
now
we're all the drum i said right
patience
and shuffle the cards
thanks
[Applause]
we begin now with james baldwin and a
speech he gave at the national press
club in december 1986
his remarks were delivered just 11
months before his death from cancer
correspondent for the lowell
massachusetts sun
i'd like to welcome our members to this
luncheon today as well as their guests
and to those individuals listening to
this broadcast live over the national
public radio stations 303 of them or
those who will be watching it later on
one of the 2300 cable systems affiliated
with c-span cable satellite public
affairs network
before going any further with today's
luncheon i would like to remind our
members of some upcoming events here
next tuesday december 16th our luncheon
guest will be senator william j
fulbright that'll be the occasion of the
40th anniversary of the fulbright
scholarship program
future speakers also include nobel prize
winning economist james buchanan on
january 23rd and energy secretary john
harrington on february 19th
i would like to remind those of you in
the audience that if you have any
questions for our speaker today i trust
that you will
please write them down on the cards on
your table and send them to the front i
will ask as many questions as time
permits
i would now like to introduce our guest
at the head table i ask them to please
stand when i call out their names
briefly
and the ads the ad insta withhold their
applause until i'm completed from left
is uh bernard shaw of cable news network
i don't get any respect
lena williams of the new york times
adrian farrell a writer on foreign
affairs and a member of our club
speakers committee who organized today's
luncheon
jean-maurice repair of the french
embassy
randy allen vice president of pyramid
video and chairman of the club speakers
committee
dorothy gilliam of the washington post
h finley lewis the washington bureau
chief of the minneapolis tribune and
ernest white of wdcu fm and washington
living magazine
[Applause]
[Music]
our guest today author james baldwin
offers a fine lesson for those of us who
are writers and those who us are readers
that we both shall well heed it's a
message of clarity wisdom insight and
determination
this message it was and remains one that
needs to be heard
23 years ago i'm sorry 33 years ago mr
baldwin's first book go tell on the
mountain was published but it was 23
years ago that his essay the fire next
time was one first bought an
international claim that essays
dissecting the us racial problems
the road from there has been one of a
continual climb into deeper respect from
his peers and a reaffirmation of that
message in essays plays in more than a
dozen books
there have been times however when mr
baldwin's message
while on target has been somewhat
controversial
he criticized the american establishment
for failing to meet with revolutionary
leaders such as ho chi minh mao tong and
fidel castro
he's argued that the myth of white
supremacy is crumbling superiority is
crumbling that warning that television
has obliterated recent history and left
teenagers with an absence of a feeling
of community
he has noted that while the united
states was willing to liberate grenada
is made no effort to do the same for
cities like detroit or new york
and he has said that the problems of the
inner cities such as drug and alcohol
abuse went unattended until they reached
into the white areas of the city
those are strong words from a man who
once said he was too shy to approach
langston hughes when they both lived in
harlem
mr
baldwin said at that time there were two
heartlands a division between the black
people who lived on the hill and himself
who he called a raggy funky black
shoeshine
boy mr baldwin was born in new york city
august 2nd 1924 the first of nine
children he's a grandson of a slave and
a son of a preacher and he grew up in
harlem began speaking the gospel at age
14.
after graduation he held a variety of
jobs to support himself and his writing
the writing first started appearing
after world war ii publication first in
the nation in such magazines as harper's
american mercury the new leader partisan
review and commentary
those works drew mr baldwin into the new
york intelligentsia but in 1948 feeling
frustrated with both the church and
america's oppression of blacks he moved
to paris for nine years
as was the case for many artists paris
was an important breath of fresh air to
mr baldwin he wrote that he felt as
though he suddenly came out of a dark
tunnel and found himself beneath the
open sky
mr baldwin now divides his time between
homes in new york city and southern
france please join me in welcoming mr
james baldwin to the national press club
[Applause]
thank you all very much good afternoon
i am very pleased to be here
i
am a little surprised
when i agreed when i knew i was going to
come
here given my luck of course
the white house was
[Music]
not
in trouble
and now um
i'm terribly aware
of that house on the hill
which is in trouble which means that we
are
and i'm curious i'm just going to
improvise around what's on my mind for a
few minutes and then you will ask me
questions and maybe we can have a kind
of rap session
if the white house is in trouble we are
now the question is how we got there
and i have
some suggestions
uh purely subjective subjects
suggestions coming out of my
life but it seems to me that part of
what part of what upsets me certainly is
uh what i call sometimes myself
the view from here
now that implies a great many things
first of all i'm speaking as an american
citizen
i'm speaking as also as a grandson of a
slave
i'm speaking as a product and a member
of
a certain democracy
and is a product and
issue
of a certain very complex history
someone who represents
a very complex country
which insists on being simple
minded
simplicity
it occurs to me has occurred to me
more than once
in my somewhat stormy life
simplicity is
taken to be a great american virtue
along with sincerity
and the result of this is
if you are simple minded enough
you can become
i didn't want to go that far
[Laughter]
and
as long as you're sincere in what you
say
you haven't got to know what you're
talking about
these are
the american virtues
two of them anyway
one of the results of this
is that immaturity
is taken to be a virtue too
so that
someone like that to say john wayne
the late john wayne
who spent most of his time on screen
admonishing indians
um
[Applause]
was it no necessity
to grow up
in a movie made during the witch hunt
era of american life
when joe mccarthy
kind of illiterate senator but very
sincere man
was finding communists everywhere
somebody made a movie called
my son john
which thought
well i won't bother to talk about the
cast
story of a woman whose son is
turns out to be
a communist defector
and she has to somehow
reconcile herself to this and
cooperate with the fbi to save her son's
soul
perfectly okay
all right
but
she says one point
to her husband who's an american legion
american legion hero
a model of simplicity
and he understands before anybody else
does
that his son is really a communist
how do you understand this because he is
such a virtuous american
and
he's probably willing to put his son to
death because his son is a communist
all right i didn't make that movie you
know it um
may
or may not have made a lot of money but
it represented something in the climate
of the times and something very very
profound
in the american experience or the
american
refusal to endure or accept experience
one of the things it seems to me that
it's always contributed to this
adoration of innocence
this adoration of immaturity
so that we really do get
representing us a post adolescent who
was almost 80 years old
and
we think of this as um
as a virtue
one of the things that is always
afflicted
the american reality
and the american vision
is this aversion to history
history
is not
something you read about in a book
history is not even the past
it's the present
because everybody operates
whether or not we know it out of a star
out of assumptions which are produced
and produced only by
our history
now the issue of this country is not
bloodier than that of other countries
but it's bloody
it is not more criminal than that of
other countries but it's criminal
or in short it is not worse in the
history of france or england or
any country
we can name
but it's different
it's different for several reasons
a few weeks ago
i was
having to have the tv set on
and i was
i was flicking it
aimlessly for a while and then i started
and then i started doing it deliberately
and i what i was i watching i was
watching a series of images
all of them bloody
guns
all kinds of weapons corpses
cowboys and indians good guys and bad
guys
and for a moment it seemed to me
that this these comp these compulsive
set of images
i presented to myself i was watching
a person a human being
who was very very very very ill
and was trapped in these images
could not be released from them
because all of these images
come out of
the history which we always deny
it is
important to recognize that we did steal
the land from the people who were here
before us we stole it
and we never honored a single treaty
made with a person
that person known as the american indian
and i repeat we're not talking about the
past we're talking about the present
we did
enslave millions of people because
another reason because they were black
and we did
make a lot of money
out of slave labor
neither is this uncommon
it is a part of human history
but
it is one thing to do something
and another to deny it
the doctrine of manifest destiny
reassure
all white americans
that
as white people as regarding the
civilization
they're the right and therefore the duty
to exterminate whatever stood in the way
of the superior civilization
and as for
sample
though it may be it can be argued
but is it slavery is a strange road to
take in order to civilize someone
that was the argument
so that we
can see if we
examine our legends
that very shortly after i was
discovered in africa
where i was the
sometimes noble savage
i was in the twinkling of an eye
after the middle passage
i am found on the metro government
backlot
singing and dancing
the global savage now transformed into
the happy donkey
no one quite knows how this happened
we are living
with these myths
until today
and
it corrupts the view from here
because part of what has happened
is in the in the effort to
deny
whence we came
we've had to make up a series of myths
about it
and this cannot replace reality
the reason that the native american is
called indian for example
is due to
a monumental era
on the part of
um adventurer
sent out by queen isabella of spain
to find a passage to india
chris got lost
and when he woke up and saw these people
surrounding him
since he had to tell queen isabella
something
he said these are indians
and took one back to spain we call this
era
has
persisted in the language until this
hour
in a similar way
once i became the happy donkey because
if i wasn't the happy doctor
then something then i was a slave then
even if i wasn't happy
then something was wrong with slavery
so i had to be happy
to keep the master happy
to say nothing because of the mysteries
out of this
profound misapprehension
has come a system of reality
a system
of ideas even
a system of thought
which makes reality very hard to reach
when the slave was discovered and put in
chains
obviously he was debased along with his
women and his children
but he was not the only creature who was
debased
at that moment
the man the people who put him in chains
had also
become less than human
and debase themselves
with a further disadvantage
whereas
the slave must know the master
because the masses
is the slave's life is in the master's
hands
and the master cannot fool a slave
but the slave can pull the master
because the master wants to be fooled
my father
all the years that i lived with him
never dreamed of telling a white person
the truth about anything
it's something that rented his mind to
do so
he didn't care what they thought didn't
care if they lived he died he loaded
them
that was very frightening for me to
watch
my turn came too
but i could see
what had happened
and the reason it's important now
is that
out of this endeavor
what we call the white american
has created only the [ __ ]
he wants to see
the reason that's important
and terrifying and corruptive using here
is because
when the same white man looks
around the world
sees
only the [ __ ] he wants to see
and that is morally dangerous
for
the future of this country
for our present fortunes
the world is full of all kinds of people
who live quite beyond the confines
of the american imagination
and who
have nothing whatever to do
with the guild-ridden vision of the
world
which controls so much
of our life and our thinking
in which paralysis paralyzes very nearly
our moral sense
we are living in a world in which every
body and everything is interdependent
it is not white this world
is not black either
the future of this world depends on
everyone in this room
and that future depends on
to what extent and by what means
we liberate ourselves
from a vocabulary
which now cannot bear the weight of
reality
thank you
[Applause]
uh mr baldwin uh
these questions come from the audience
and i'll ask as many as i can as i say
and we have a nice wide variety
there is a movement of brilliant young
women writers tony morrison alice walker
others
could you please comment
on their the influences
including yourself that have produced
this movement
that's not that's by no means an easy
question is it
partly because i know all those ladies
and their friends have friends of mine
and i'm always a little
frightened because afraid to leave
somebody out
but anyway i know them all
i'm not sure i can answer your question
i think i think i think first of all
that um
the arrival of tony and maya and paul
marshall and alice walker for example
louise marriott
it was um
in a way inevitable
it had to come about because of the role
that black women
have played in this country
and more specifically the role the black
women have played in the lives of all
black men
and
that has always been a very troubled
and even dangerous role
because of the position of the black man
in this republic
which makes the situation of black women
who have got to we've got to respect
their fathers
and find a way to protect
and protect their sons and their lovers
without emasculating them
it was time it is time that she began to
tell something of
that story
it is in some sense has been condemned
but i think
i welcome it as
the ventilation so to speak of a family
quarrel
what they have to say is
some are terrifying
but true
and as for the influences
i've
had where to begin
or not to go back at least as far as w.b
dubois
the influence is being in short that
work done by black people especially
black people
to clarify the role of black people here
because most white historians
and most like most white commentators
until today
so busy justifying it that they can only
lie about it
so that tony and maya
are excavating
us all
helping to escape all of us from a very
dangerous myth
do you feel the problems of southern
africa are properly framed by our media
in the context of the american
experience
or should these african issues be
examined more closely in their own
african context
well i think that i think the american
american vision of
of africa
has got to be
compulsively
um defensive
we all south africa implicates everyone
in this room
it brings into question all it reveals
the real meaning of the civilizing
mission
because that's what that's how africa
was civilized but we're watching the
installment of johannesburg
is the process
no matter how one might want to pretty
mean pretty it up
no matter what hollywood hollywood has
told us
the african context
in which it should be examined of course
scarcity exists in the american
imagination
and one of the reasons for that
is that it brings into focus in the
uneasy american imagination the real
role of black people in this country in
the uneasy american imagination
the truth being
as concerns the presence of black people
here
that in the generality white people have
never never never
accepted the real meaning of it
and are unable to imagine
even though it is absolutely true
that this is not and never has been
never can be
a white country
we have been here together too long
and the vocabulary which we are avoiding
has got to deal with that before it can
deal with anything as vivid as as
dangerous
and as overwhelming as a south african
situation
here's a related question sir that
perhaps you can answer
do you think that this administration
and i assume the questioner means the
reagan administration
has a different attitude toward the
black population in south africa
and its concern about the nationalists
in nicaragua if so is this racial
your name could be easy
well um
they have no concern that has to be very
blunt about it
i don't think this administration is
only concerned with nicaragua either
it has a concern with what it takes to
be its interest
what strikes me
is that both nicaragua and south africa
are expected to remain the pawns of the
so-called free world forever
of course we are against the freedom
south african black freedom because it
means communism or that's what people
say
but we begin to feed them in nicaragua
for the same reason
and we are not the remotest notion of
what we're talking about in either case
period and it is racial
mr baldwin the questioner wants to know
if you've seen the movie she's got to
have it
if not i'll tell you about it after the
luncheon
but however they're not interested in my
opinion they want to know what you think
about the movie have you seen it i
haven't seen it okay well sorry
okay
well we'll go to another question then
a number of black male writers who have
criticized the portrayal of black men
as abusers rapists addicts
portrait often drawn by black women one
which black men feel perpetuates a
negative stereotype
do you feel that the image of black men
is being falsely portrayed
i think the image of black men in this
country has always been false it's late
in the day blame it on black
women um
the color purple is of course the most
controversial of
these
books or movies
and the only way i can answer that
question is to say that um
well the movie i thought was i thought
the movie was awful really
and in the movie i felt that if you're
going to
give me that
that particular man that black man
then you got to tell me more about him
you know
i quite you know i quite see you know
black men i can do all those things
but then there's gonna be something
wrong with it
you know and you have to you have to let
me know something more than
the catalog of these of this man's
brutality
if he were if he were white
then he would be you know
paul newman were playing that cat you
realize he was very very sick and he'd
have all your sympathy you'd hope he get
well
but the black image is very very
different all you got to do in order to
do that is be black
well it's um it's an image of black
people which is not entirely to be
entirely alex walker's fault no that is
the way the republic has seen black
people black men
since they've heard of black men
and
that has had a terrible effect on black
women
and
on in that context
if
if the
motive is to
be liberated from these images by
by exercising them really
then i you know um amen
freedom
freedom is very difficult to achieve and
it's very and the process is very very
awkward
but in order to demolish an image
sometimes you have to hold it up to the
light and see
what weight it will bear see where it
comes from see what you see if you can
live with it and you can live with it
get rid of it
that answers your question
this one was written apparently as
you're answering the last one as a
follow-up could you please go into
detail about the role or the comportment
of today's american blackmail
[Music]
what should be the rule
well let's have to say something a
little difficult
going back into
my own history in black history
what should be the role of the
comportment of today's american
one of the difficulties about being a
black man in this country has always
been
the difficulty being a white man
because it is assumed
it is assumed so profoundly that no one
has ever questioned it i think
that black man wants to be
a white man
white men
as i have observed
i'm not sure they want to be white it's
got to be exhausting
tendency flexing your muscles and you
know
conquering the world
and smiling
and you know it wears white people out
furthermore
black people always
in the presence of white people you're
you watch you you're watching an
imitation
and you realize this if you try to
imitate it because you cannot imitate an
imitation
therefore the role of the black man in
today's america in today's america
it's got to be what it always really was
or what the republic always feared it
was
he is a man
and
he a man cannot be told what to do man
cannot be defined by others
and
there's nothing new about that
what the question really means is how
should we alter
the american model
so that both the black man and the white
man can be free that's what the question
means
i apologize to the person wrote this
because i'm having trouble reading it so
i'll get through it as well as i can you
talk about facing reality at least by
white america
don't you think it's time for black
america
to
realize
that a great deal
of its problems are tr are trying to
blame them on the past in white america
isn't it time for blacks to face up
to their own realities to other
realities
i think that's the general yeah i
drifted a question excuse me
well i've heard i've heard that
before
i don't think
that um
black people in the generality certainly
can be accused of blaming their
situation on the past
or indeed blaming
a situation on anybody
the situation is much too vivid
much too terrible
for that kind of self-indulgence but it
isn't
people i started out with
history is not the past situation in the
black community in this country is
abominable
because this is a racist country and
every institution in this country is a
racist institution
and the very last thing the republic
really wants is an autonomous black
community
anywhere
everybody knows for example
that if you build a school in a ghetto
you built a disaster factory
and the answer to that is not to bust a
child to another neighborhood
the answer to that is to rebuild a city
so human beings can live in a city
cities are not supposed to be built for
money
and to make a few people rich
now we want to deal with that we've got
to go there
in the meantime there's a point in
blaming the black community but being
upset about the community because the
community has always been involved with
the republic
when we tried before some time ago
there was a school strike in harlem in
which blacks and puerto ricans
came into the schools here and declaring
themselves responsible for the education
of their children
and it was a very successful strike i
was there like nieces and nephews in
school
it was broken
by the united federation of teachers and
by the city
because they did not want first of all
that those billions of dollars
which is which is the education system
it is a billion dollar business
they do not want that money controlled
by blacks and puerto ricans and that is
what we're up against and it's not the
past and there's no point in blaming
black people for it
[Applause]
a few questions here that are related on
a somewhat different topic why did you
choose france as your residence or one
of your residences do you consider
yourself an exile or an expatriate
how would you compare the french
attitude toward blacks
with that of america or is there as much
racism as france as here in the states
i went to france
in 1948
when i was quite young i went there with
forty dollars
no french one-way ticket
or in other words
i was getting out of here
i would go i didn't want to go to paris
as leave new york
the reason i left new york was because i
knew that one one fine tuesday
somebody's gonna call me [ __ ] just
once too often just once too often and
somebody was going to die
and i didn't care which one of us it was
so i split i didn't know what's gonna
happen to me in paris but i knew what
was going to happen to me here
i grew up in paris in a way and then i
came back
in a sense one can say that my life in
paris prepared me to go south
because i've never gone south if i'd
stayed here
i wouldn't have been
if i say it alive i'd have been a junkie
or a prisoner
i'd been in no state to go to montgomery
alabama
as
as for
i don't consider myself
i don't listen to myself in exile
i stayed away long enough to grow up as
i put it and now i'm a commuter i
suppose
and um
the doctrine of white supremacy which
but which is what i mean by racism
comes out of the so-called old world
it wasn't born in america it was brought
here
and when i first went to paris
or to europe
friendship of all could always say um
adventure is what i would say you must
be very happy to be here but we don't
treat negroes who are treated in the
states
and um
we're not racist like the americans are
well
i looked around me
and i could see that the reason that
they could be so tolerant as they
thought
was because they didn't have any [ __ ]
in paris
[Applause]
they were working for them far away you
know senegal algeria so forth
and so it was not a part of the social
fabric
and of course was very good for me in a
way except my mama didn't raise no fools
you know
i realized almost once the algerian was
[ __ ] in paris
because i was i was poor i was so i was
i was with them
in the same jails with them the same
hotel sleeping shifts
another way i know the way they were
treated
and in a way that's what drove me home
because i could see what was happening
didn't happen in my country was the same
thing that was happening in france and
since i was not french couldn't do
anything there i came home with i didn't
want to duck it
now the doctor in the white supremacy
which seemed to
uh
have
have affected europe less the cities of
europe london paris belgium
berlin
it's come back to europe
and the same thing is going on in the
european cities is going on in the
american cities
and for the same reason
how would you compare the artistic
and creative climate in france to that
in the united states
well i guess the fairest thing to say
is that
the european experience let's put it
that way
is old enough for them to
they're not afraid of artists
now
this is this doesn't mean they love them
or do they respect them
they just know that every once in a
while somebody like that is bound to
come along
so they tolerate it
and if you know and
if you live long enough or if you are
safely dead
you are they build a statue to you
in the meantime you're on your own
thanks
the questioner asks as a white person
reading some of your stories in books i
felt a great deal of prejudice and
hatred against a white race did i
misinterpret
a great deal of hatred
uh prejudice and hatred against whites
i don't think that i've had the my
life's too short for one thing
no no i don't think i don't think it's
either prejudice or hatred
against whites
after all
and i may say so i wrote another country
and i wrote javanese room which can
hardly be called anti-white diatribes
but i think that i think whenever a
black person
tries to tell the truth about a
situation
to white people to people who think
they're white because why does why is a
state of mind it's even a moral choice
every time if my testimony is true
my testimony is a black
citizen of this country or a black
would-be citizen of this country
and my testimony is true that the
american myth is a lie
and when this collision happens i'm
accused
of being prejudiced against white people
i have better sense and don't have that
much time i don't have some white person
locked up in my skull
walking around me every day and every
hour
white people have a black person they're
locked up in their skills their skulls
and that is how that's why they treat
black people the way they do
you see what i mean
[Applause]
there's uh several questions here you
can choose which one you want to answer
they generally deal on the same broad
topic how would you assess the state of
race relations in america today how much
change do you see since the fire next
time what are the true issues issues
before american civil rights leaders
today are any false so on
you'll see them all here
well it's a very difficult question to
answer this no seriously because it's um
the question is
the question's sincere but it's posed in
such
let me well you know what i would like
to do what i would really like to do
is an idea which maybe maybe you can
take hold of in this room
i want to establish
proposal
white history week
[Applause]
because the answer to these questions is
not to be found in me
but in that history which produces these
questions
it's late in the day to be talking about
race relations what are you talking
about
and as long as we have race relations
how can they deteriorate or improve
i am not a race and neither are you
[Applause]
no we're talking about the life
and death of this country
and one of the things i'm not joking
when i talk about white history week
one of the things that most afflicts
this country is that why people don't
know who they are where they come from
that's why you think i'm a problem
but i am not the problem your history is
and as long as you pretend you don't
know your history you're going to be the
prisoner of it
and there's no question you're
liberating me because you can't liberate
yourselves
we're in this together
and finally
when white people quote unquote white
people talk about progress relationship
with black people
all they are saying and all they can
possibly mean by the word progress
is how quickly and how thoroughly i
become white
i don't want to become white i want to
grow up and so should you
thank you
with the deaths of malcolm x and
reverend king in the 1960s black america
lost its most activist and disobedient
leaders
with the shift of black emphasis to
politics in corporate america is this a
positive change in the right direction
i don't know how to answer that question
because i don't quite know what the what
the question it means about corporate
america
and i don't quite know what connection
that has
with human freedom or what we call
democracy
and changing the right direction
i think that the future
is not nearly as simple as americans
like to think
i'm not convinced the machine is going
to resolve so many problems
i know that we've got
to
confront i think the fact that if we
don't share the earth
we may we blow it we're gonna blow it up
i think we have to rethink everything we
think is true now
because
it's not going to be true tomorrow
the the question supposes a future which
is more or less coherent
and which is safe
but in fact the moral choice we have yet
to make
does not guarantee that anyone in this
room has a future
and the only way we can
accommodate ourselves to that
is to rethink and recreate
our vocabulary
which includes
the human race
we are all of them are in this in this
room at the mercy of whether or not we
know it the european vision of the world
and that vision
is obsolete
what is the proper role of the black
politician today in american society
i would think the black the proper role
of the black politician in american
society
is to do what some people in fact are
doing which is to
to resist
the definitions
to instruct
and to attempt to liberate the children
who are the most crucial issue
and to have the courage
to contest the american reality
it may sound outrageous for example but
consider
this
when i was born when i was growing up
various people blew themselves up in
homemade stills
and died drinking bathtub gin
because
alcohol was illegal and dope was legal
it did not mean that anybody stopped
drinking
not at all
it just meant that
various people made tremendous fortunes
out of the illegal liquor
and various people died out of a legal
liquor a new form of crime was created
and that's all that happened
now we want to get to the the heart of
the dope problem
legalize it
that destroys the profit motive
and may save our children nobody who has
a habit who can afford it is going to go
to jail
so it's a law which in operation
can be used only against the poor
and a law like that is a bad law
and it has not stopped anybody
from his fix it just puts some people in
jail and some people under
the ground
because a whole lot of money is being
made
on the anti-dope law
which does not work
that is one of the things i think a
black politician might suggest to white
politicians
if you see what i mean
what contempt excuse me what
contemporary topic or topics interest
you the most these days
i think i'm really going to be obsessed
with the future of the young
because
we
the elders are responsible for that
and um
i myself i think you know i learned a
lot from young people because
young people unlike or unlike people my
age
in the generality i was on the road
really you know to find out if it was
true with people who were telling me
that the youth of america became
hopelessly apathetic in middle age and
dead
there are great many things and the
people i met and i've been on the road
for a year
but none of those things
the truth i think is that their elders
have betrayed them
by throwing jaguars at them
tv sets
and other kind of paraphernalia
instead of trying to teach them
still trying to raise them
instead of loving them
and that they've been abandoned to the
dream of safety
and children
unlike their elders
are not very easily fooled
that's what fascinates me today
would you please comment on wolf
soldienka and the nobel prize awarded to
him in 1986
was that a political act
well
on one level certainly it's a political
act you know um
a concession perhaps even
on the other hand
um soyuncu deserves it
it uh it's a political gesture it will
not have the effect whoever
blue academy might have hoped
but
it is a symptom of
what has to be
what has to become
you see the question is impossible to
answer because
the suggestion is that the politics of
tomorrow
is um like the politics of politics of
today
and it ain't gonna just it's not gonna
be that way
no one no one in this room now really
knows
what a political gesture really means
because no one is able to envision the
future it's meant to bring about that
makes sense to you
why do you believe that simplicity isn't
a is an american virtue
isn't the simple man the virtuous model
in most societies certainly in communist
states where dissent is unpatriotic
certainly why do you believe that
simplicity is an american virtue
i don't know if you said
quite like that uh but isn't the simple
man a virtuous model in most societies
certainly in communist states where
dissent is unpatriotic
descent is unperiodic everywhere
the purpose of the state is to remain
the state let's not be romantic about
that
and i didn't say that simplicity is an
american virtue i said americans think
it's an american virtue
and isn't the simple man the virtuous
model in most societies certainly in
communist states who conquered his
sentence and patriotic
the simple man depends well it depends
on what you mean by simplicity
simple is not necessarily simple-minded
or one goes this far and say that no man
is simple
that is not possible it's a
contradiction in terms
every society has a model of itself
and every society's model of itself is
false
let us face that too
i don't
know
where i started
no state
is anxious to have dissenters in it
including this one
and there's more than one way to skin a
cat
and more than one way to silence a
dissenter
mr baldwin there's another one of these
threesomes here that we're going to try
to make into one question
are aren't you perpetuating the white
black problem by criticizing whites and
glorifying blacks
blacks and whites are supposed to be one
and the same don't you think black
history week and similar days weeks keep
us separate
and of all this do you feel that racism
has accurately been cited as a reason
for so many of today's problems
well i'll take the middle question first
um
i was not joking about white history
week
after all
i was told quite some time ago when i
was growing up that george washington
couldn't tell a lie
and um
did not chop down the cherry tree i
forget
uh
i'm serious about that
white americans
really do not know their history
that's one of the reasons they're in
trouble
and i when i when i suggested white
history week i'm not really this power
you know making a parody of black
history week
but i'm suggesting
that the truth about this country
is buried in the myths that white people
have about themselves and they have
these myths have to be excavated
can only be excavated by white people
or in other words i may know this
history the history of this country
better than
whatever teacher is trying to teach my
child
because i it's in my interest to
understand it
in order to be liberated from it
most white americans cling to the idea
of the of being white
and you know because they don't want to
find out well but else they might
be but if i know that i have black and
white ancestors
so do you
and no one in this country can prove
they're white
no one would dare to try to prove that
and i'm not trying to glorify black
people or denigrate white people i'm
trying to point out that we are whether
we like it or not connected
and that a connection should be our
triumph and our glory instead of our
shame
uh before asking our guests the last
question
i'd like to present mr baldwin with a
certificate appreciation for appearing
at the national press club
as well as a national press club
paperweight thank you
now i know we've asked our guests many
hard questions today but some people may
think this is the hardest one of them
all
mr baldwin which of your books do you
consider the best and why
[Applause]
i think every writer
i'll be honest honestly i can be i think
everybody has two answers to that
question
and the first answer is the next one
it's true
and if i have a favorite if any author
has a favorite among the books he's
published
um
he's always a little bit afraid to say
so but i'm going to take a chance and
the reason that when
the author
has a favorite book very often
it's because the book was so badly
treated it's like having a
having a bad you know a child of yours
badly treated it's unjustly you know you
know you shouldn't treat it in that way
and the novel i'm thinking about being
so badly treated
is that tell me how long the train's
been gone
thanks
once again i'd like to thank our guest
mr james baldwin for appearing at this
national press club luncheon this
concludes today's luncheon thank you
[Music]
writer james ball